ladies and gentlemen i'm not sure what
the biggest news of the day is but
apparently it is that donald trump has
been permanently banned from twitter
they've outright removed his account all
of his tweets just gone memory hold
censored out of there and the reason i
say i don't know the biggest news story
of the day is because the democrats also
announced they are going to be
impeaching the president on monday
things are getting just very very weird
so we heard
that apple and google were threatening
parlor
that if they didn't overhaul their
moderation uh or introduce heavy
moderation they would remove parlor from
the app stores
i don't know exactly what's going on but
i can tell you i pulled up the google
play store and parlor ain't there so
maybe it's already happened because we
actually have uh one of the experts not
to mention ian is an expert as well
on social media censorship and
moderation we've got bill ottman ceo of
mines
minds.com one of these
other social media platforms which has
you guys have a unique approach to rule
breaking and censorship and stuff the
jury system right yep yeah so juries i
mean why not empower the community to to
help moderate and imagine if facebook
twitter
they took their tens of thousands of
moderators and actively actually
proactively
engaged with
people who have
mental issues or are extreme like we
have to realize that
extreme psychology is just something
that exists and we have to
deal with it in a way that's not banning
them off the platforms does that well
because then what happens now is they're
saying
you're gonna get banned everybody goes
to parlor and so then the big companies
attack the infrastructure that allows
people to even find parlor but everybody
as you know ian who is a regular on the
show hello you we are we you ran
moderation yeah i co-founded mines with
bill technically i came in what six
months after you guys had it
2010. no no
like a year it was with the og developer
and um that was really fun it was before
john got involved and it was just me and
you in john's basement you know
talking about where the future of tech's
going to be in 2010-ish
then we went to occupy wall street i
think we were all at occupy wall street
actually but you you uh you were the
band hammer you were yeah these awful
trump supporters just getting rid of
them saying you can't you can't like
trump you've got to get out of here so
the way it would work is if a admin on
mines makes a wrong decision then a user
can appeal it and then it goes to random
12 users who vote on it and so we in we
launched a jury system to keep ourselves
in check
i think you got to have more than 12
people though
because like there's this margin of
error i guess but i understand the 12.
no that's a variable because like you
know you know what i see happening is
not first of all i'll say that's like an
excellent system but i see what i see
happening is look at twitter you know
they they keep banning trump supporters
eventually the 12 people you're going to
get are going to be one political
ideology who are going to be like yeah
bam and ban him
in the early days it was just me i would
be sitting in a queue looking at stuff
and be like okay our policy is we only
ban it if it violates the us
constitution so i have to
define the u.s constitution for each
post i have to like make these supreme
court judgment calls on it was insane
stress and sure one human to have to go
but like you probably saw pictures where
you're like that's easy gone yes there
were there were easy ones and they were
really hard ones and and
this is what they're doing
but can we just say that like someone's
saying go kill that guy well that's
illegal yeah no it's not imminent
so imminent no they changed themselves
to true threat yeah who who did it
one time we got uh contacted by
pennsylvania and you know they they
said legally true threat is the language
right like how do you know if someone's
being sarcastic half the time so like
sarcasm is out the window you can't
again sarcasm by the way guys does not
fly on social media and text do not be
sarcastic in text because they will they
will define it as not sarcastic for the
sake of moderation absolutely all right
so so we'll get into all this stuff
because well you know not to bury
anything in the intro but lucas hanging
out of course um yeah talking about
sarcasm i just wanted to say i'm so
happy that our tech overlords
unaccountable multinational corporations
with unlimited power
are now keeping us safe i think um
we all needed to be safe from you know
words and and sounds and and speech from
our little small little ears and our
feeble minds and uh especially words
from democratically elected government
officials i feel safe just like if i
would be in the matrix in that little
bubble energy blanket
and uh mark zuckerberg is successful
okay it is by merit that he has gained
the power to shut down the president of
the united states yes and i'm saying i'm
so happy he did this because i'm safe
from you know the bad words and sounds
and and and you know we're so safe that
you don't have to go to we are
change.org and in the right top hand
corner put in your email you could
definitely follow me on all the mainline
channels under we are change so you got
nothing to worry about we're safe and
happy and protected that's right
what are you talking about guys all
right this is great look the president
there's there's a ton of stuff going on
but beyond all of this i think
we are looking at the
exponential escalation
joe biden went on tv
and he likened holly and cruz two
sitting u.s senators
to goebbels
this is
absolutely off the rails and it's not a
joke
what we saw yesterday i i have some
ideas about what i think is going to
happen and what i'm what i'm really
worried about but it's going to get bad
all right so we'll start the show we're
going to talk about trump being banned
permanently because there's a lot of
there's a lot of questions here this is
a removal of of historical record before
we could do finishing introductions of
course don't forget lydia's here i am
here i'm pushing all the buttons over in
the corner and now that we've had that
long introduction
because everybody wanted to you know we
have so much to talk about let's just
jump to the first story from cnbc
twitter permanently suspends trump's
account
they say
the company said in a tweet it made the
decision due to the risk of further
incitement of violence saying after a
close review of recent uh tweets from
the from real donald trump account and
the context around them we have
permanently suspended the account due to
the risk of further incitement of
violence the suspension accounts to a
ban trump can no longer access his
account and his tweets and profile
picture have been deleted trump had 88.7
million followers prior to a suspension
institutional accounts like potus and
white house are still active so
what if he tweeted through at potus
something ridiculous
why wouldn't he
i hope he does he still has access to
twitter
maybe and he has the potus account it's
at po you know potus they would suspend
it until biden got inaugurated and then
they'd reinstituted that probably yeah
they say it's a step twitter has
resisted taking for all of trump's
presidency while president barack obama
was the first president to use twitter
he mainly used the institutional potus
account and did not rely on his uh on it
as heavily as trump has to get his
message out trump used his personal
twitter account to stoke supporters and
even make personal change personnel
changes before they can even make it to
the press release yeah you know what it
was this allowed trump to bypass the
media and they hated him for it yep now
i'll tell you we've got a lot of
questions here this is a historical
record the things that the president had
been tweeting but before we bring that
up in those issues let me tell you
donald trump i cannot believe
the biggest mistake made and i don't
necessarily blame him he's an old guy
you know he's not he's not social media
savvy he is pretty savvy for his age and
i'm not trying to disparage you know
people who are older
he could have at any moment
tweeted out to 88.7 million people
follow me on parlor follow me on mines
follow me and anywhere else
and then he could have had those 88.7
million choose to go somewhere else in
fact just by posting on any of these
other platforms many people would have
said what did he say where did he say it
let's go check it out the media would be
forced to cover it he didn't do it
now there are reports that the donald
trump has joined parliament this
according to fox news's sean hannity
parlor is currently being hugged to
death as they say what it basically
means is so many people are flocking to
parlor that the traffic is kind of
overloading it making it slow and hard
to use i've had no problem logging well
i've had a little trouble logging but
once i got logged in seemed like
everything was fine so they must be
dealing with it but
something trump could have done a long
time ago
now i guess we should just start by
talking about the historical precedence
of
jack dorsey and mark zuckerberg and
these tech ceos having the ability to
tell the president you cannot speak to
the american people well why is it that
an avalanche of bans happen every time
it's just like are
is there communication happening between
them
is it social pressure like what do you
think is really going on here i think
they're all cowards
and then when one network says we have
to remove this all of the rest of them
go now now it's safe for us to do
another thing we really have to
understand here is that this is a
transition of power speech is power and
if you're not able to talk to your
supporters if you're if you have a whole
political party that right now is
voiceless that's a major step in in what
i believe in an extremely wrong
direction the last time we had
censorship
the major censorship story was of course
the hunter biden story it was wrong they
were wrong about that story they
censored it for i believe in my own
opinion political needs and then it came
out that oh yeah the hunter biden story
was true after the election after the
election time after of course joe biden
you know
i don't even want to we got to be
careful with our language here uh after
the election was called for joe biden
the story popped back up in the media
yeah yeah this is i mean in my opinion
1984 just happened today
uh and wonder woman 1984 no not that was
that a coincidence unless of course it
was joe biden who grabbed the dream
stone and said i want to be president
the whole world's on fire a lot of this
is being done allegedly for your safety
but let's not discuss you know let's not
discuss it let's not lie about this is
essentially political and cultural
dominance that's exactly what it is it
was this whole system was abused before
and and this is the continuation of that
abuse of power i'll tell you what i said
it's uh a major political party
demanding of massive multinational
billion dollar corporations the removal
of their political opposition
it's a cultural coup they are removing
their opposition from the discourse
period and it's been happening for some
time and this is the most dramatic
escalation we saw back in what was it
2018 when they got rid of like jones and
like milo yiannopoulos yeah and they
they targeted certain people
that was you know a slow uptick now it
is the most dramatic people high profile
personalities not just on the right are
reporting they're losing thousands of
followers
we can't actually see
the the level by which this purge is
happening the censorship is bigger than
just the president and it could be even
hundreds of thousands of people
yeah i mean uh i i think i just lost a
thousand followers on twitter myself but
we can't say that we didn't see this
coming i mean just even what was it a
couple weeks ago we were talking about
this very topic and we talked about will
donald trump be banned and we both
agreed and said yes donald trump's going
to be banned well actually our timeline
was wrong because we said after the
inauguration i disagreed yeah i said
they would lose too much money i thought
that they you know for like you know
early on
i thought they would totally do it
because they hate the guy
but then i started talking to people who
said you know look at look at their user
base it was in decline before trump so i
think someone mentioned twitter stock
went down when they banned trump like
it's probably going to plummet in my
opinion i'm not you know i don't own any
stock on twitter but i imagine it would
go down because trump made that platform
so after the us capital moment that's
when i knew i was like oh they're gonna
they're it's gonna be you know it's
gonna be neutral it didn't take a genius
to understand that this was going to be
their crisis this was going to be the
event that they used that they're going
to exploit and that they're going to
purposely inflate as a major threat and
that's exactly what they're doing
they're doing it very disingenuously and
uh they're they're doing it on a bed of
lies and that's the another important
aspect here nothing
good is done based on a huge foundation
of lies so we have to understand that
this huge major move this huge
transition of power all is happening
under fake pretenses and uh it's it's
it's worrying they are engineering echo
chambers yes this is a global echo and
radicalization and radicalization and
see the studies show
evidence actually on both sides it is
true that social media can cause you to
go down a rabbit hole of ideology but it
is also true that communication social
media is the only way you can become
de-radicalized so there's evidence on
both sides but the overwhelming evidence
shows that there's there's massive
blowback of the censorship you're
shutting down dialogue which is our only
option
other than taking our only options for
de-escalation is communication is being
able to hear people out and not putting
people in the fringe more people are
going to be on the fringe and more
people who are on the fringe are only
going to become friends it's not the
fringe anymore it's when when they start
banning your run-of-the-mill
conservatives who voice their support
for the president you don't have to like
the president you can disagree with them
these are not like you've got a lot of
regular people and what you're doing is
we i think we talked about this before
bill it's uh actually i think i
mentioned we talked about it on joe
rogan
you take a regular person and he gets
arrested for pot and you put him in
prison with hardened criminals and you
are guess what happens to that person
yeah you know you take some young person
who's like you know
first charge they go to prison now
they're around all the you know burglars
robbers murderers
and that's what you're doing you're
putting people in these environments
yeah it's 70 million it's 70 plus
million
75 million people that voted for donald
trump and again last night i i said on
this show the censorship is about to
reach levels that we have never seen
before we are here today and
again it's only going to get we're sorry
and i cut you off no that's okay man
brandon strzok i don't know if you're
familiar he does the walk away campaign
hashtag walk away his campaign was
banned off twitter this is like a
kind-hearted good dude and
they he's the kind of guy that if you
bust him for pot and put him in prison
with a bunch of criminals he's going to
get twisted and so
they banned him they banned his entire
facebook page campaign of i don't know
50 000 people all people all his uh um
organizers and employees have now been
banned off twitter or on facebook
it's insane yeah heavy-handed insanity
this is this is another thing books are
being unpublished there's even
democratic committees calling for no-fly
lists for individuals who are a part of
the right i mean this is a new level
of authoritarianism that i nev you know
you know like it's here it's real i
remember i had a conversation with joe
rogan vagina and jack dorsey on um the
joe broken experience
and um i think i remember that at the
end of the episode i said if you keep
doing this
it is going to get really bad in this
country what you are doing and then what
did we see all throughout this year and
what did we just see in the capitol and
then i said i'm going to build a van and
they all laughed and everybody laughed i
got emails they're like oh you crazy
dude you're gonna go build a van
nothing's gonna happen ah
where are we now yeah so here's what
here's what i think
i think we're not looking at a linear
path of escalation i think we're looking
at an exponential path of escalation
when we went from
a bunch of people in dc
many of them breaking into the capitol
which i think was ridiculous and stupid
people are now dead a cop was bashed
over that's just insane but many of
these people walked right in there's
videos where the cops open the door and
and say something one cop says that he
agrees with their right to protest and
as they waltz on in some of these people
are bewildered but listen
i saw that and i thought to myself that
the initial reaction will be
overwhelmingly negative
now i think because of the mass purge
you're going to start seeing an
overwhelmingly positive reaction from
people who feel like they've been
excised from society
so there were a lot of people posting on
twitter that they felt that their
opinions were watered down out of fear
of being banned well don't worry twitter
just did the hard work for you now these
people have been kicked off after they
said they followed the rules not
everybody did a lot of people being
banned are like you know advocating for
some crazy stuff but there are a lot of
people who are saying things like well i
shouldn't say anything you know my and
some there's tweets saying i think we're
all holding back
they get banned now what okay i guess
there's no point anymore so here's what
i think
i think after what we saw
the immediate reaction was
insane you've got politicians like corey
bush and aoc demanding the expulsion of
republicans that supported trump simon
and schuster a major book publisher
announced they would they're breaking
their contract with senator josh hawley
he challenged them saying he's going to
sue him
this is
i mean it's it's dramatic escalation
where the culture is being split
people are being demonized at an
ever-increasing rate and now we've come
to the point where you actually have joe
biden going on tv and likening two
sitting u.s centers to nazi
propagandists this level of demonization
and dehumanization is the precursor to
dramat to to horrifying things i'll i'll
spare some of the more hyperbolic words
but when you look back at history
historical civil wars the start of major
wars this is the kind of thing that
happens just before and what do you
think is going to happen when uh when
the incoming president announces the
wall street journal reported this
sweeping new uh domestic terror laws joe
biden's announced while calling sitting
republicans
likening them to you know nazi
propagandists
what do you think that demonization will
lead to the demands for expulsion do you
think that the republicans are going to
be like we're so sorry democrats no
they're these the supporters are being
forced into a totally different echo
chamber reality where people are angry
we had david cross
tweet that he wanted blood whether
whether it was a joke or whatever that
point oh no that's the problem don't
don't no don't care sarcasm doesn't work
on the internet i guess not in the text
it's similar to sacha baron cohen being
you know
crazy yeah it's like don't you
understand that comedians need to be
protected too this is coming for you
yeah people don't understand people on
the left you're going to be affected by
this sooner or later as soon as your
paths cross the establishment and the
talking points and the narrative that
they want to push i don't care who you
are it could even happen at blm blm
still hasn't you know i don't think had
their meetings had their meeting with
biden
last i saw in a few couple days i don't
know if i may stand corrected here but
anyone could stand in the way of this
big unaccountable totalitarian monster
monster that holds one of the biggest
sacred powers in the world one of the
things that makes america great more
than any other place in the world is our
free speech once you get rid of that
once you limit that once you stop
allowing people the ability to freely
communicate with each other we are in
uncharted territories where it is ripe
for abuse so the heartbreaking thing tim
that you kind of alluded to is that
regular
democrats and republicans cannot even
speak to each other they
you know families are being torn apart
there is there is a tweet from a young
woman ratting out her mom for being at a
protest i think the precursor protest
not the one at the capitol but the night
before saying this is my mom here's her
name here's my dad and then the mom got
fired that's crazy stuff
they're breaking up families do you see
the usa today uh article where they put
out 29 pictures of people that were at
the capitol if you can help us find
their names and phone numbers give us
their information and help us find these
criminals remember remember when andy
noe
just tweeted out this individual has
been arrested and the left said he is
creating kill lists and doxing people
and they started smearing him and
attacking him and now media across the
country is putting up people's names
saying find them find them
sure criminals people accused of many
crimes by all means send your tips but
i'm talking about the double standard
andy no would simply be like the police
arrested this individual
and then they would attack him for it
then you get the media coming out now
saying we don't know who these people
are what they were doing in fact what if
some of these people were credentialed
journalists elijah schaefer for instance
of blaze tv a reporter was getting
attacked relentlessly by people on
social media i'll admit some of his
tweets were a little bombastic he had
one tweet where he called it a
revolution okay dude chill but he is a
credentialed member of the press who
works for the blaze tv he got banned by
facebook probably because of these hit
pieces and then only after i think glenn
came out and said what you know and
complained about it they reinstated him
that's the danger of publishing a face
and then saying find him because we all
saw what happened after the boston
bombing on reddit when all these
good-hearted redditors said we must find
these criminals and end up doxing random
innocent people
that's the problem so you have andy no
here's the persons whose picture they
were arrested on this charge and they
threaten him and they attack him and
they accuse him of doxing and he's a
villain he's a bad guy
now the media is totally on board
totally okay with going even beyond that
and saying identify these people and
they're doing it they're doing it
they're doing you know they're
publishing names and here's the problem
there's no actual empirical data or
evidence that shows what they're doing
is making the world a safer place in
fact the opposite and so what we're
actually trying to do is on a on a
10-year basis a b test
a b test a strategy and see who can have
a higher rate of de-radicalization
here's the thing we are going to be able
to prove that we have a higher rate of
de-radicalization on minds
because you cannot de-radicalize someone
that you have just banned their rate of
de-radicalization will be zero
and i i say this all the time
if if you have somebody who who does bad
things and then one day they come out
and they apologize accept their apology
i mean maybe not the second or third
time you know it's up to you but if
someone's like you know i shouldn't have
been doing those things please accept my
apology you say yes
please come join us doing the right
thing if you don't they'll say that i
have no opportunity but to go to anyone
who will be willing to accept me so if
you've got someone who makes hate speech
and they're you know they're going on
twitter and they're saying rabble rebel
and offensive words and you decide the
best way to get rid of them is to ban
them the only place they can go is to
where everyone agrees with them and
they're allowed to you know say whatever
they want if you truly don't want them
to believe these things the best thing
you could do is talk to them like that
woman from the westboro baptist church
that was on twitter right people started
reaching out to her and then she flipped
from being a member of this this church
to being like hey that was wrong i
should have been saying these things
people really changed my mind and were
nice to me but i don't think they want
this
this this is what i think you know i i
in my opinion i think they want the
violence ted cruz came out and said we
all need to put the anger aside and come
together and aoc responded by saying no
you should be expelled from congress
okay well that's just going to make
things worse
he literally said can we put the anger
aside and come together and you attacked
him for it to score brownie points on
the internet or whatever i guess
so then ted cruz has no opportunity
whatsoever to come together with anyone
so they won't and then his followers
won't either and then the
hyperpolarization continues cnn getting
nine million you know viewers their
biggest ever
and you have this handoff between cuomo
and don lemon where they're scoffing and
insulting and berating and degrading
instead of being calm and serious even
shep smith get that off the tv we're not
showing this that's not true
that is not how you handle conflict
these people have no idea what they're
doing yeah the only answer to bad speech
is good speech and if you start to limit
it you again putting people on the
fringe and you're starting to expand it
i remember during the kind of infancy of
the internet and kind of growing up in
that day and age and thinking this is
absolutely incredible this is an amazing
tool that allows people to speak to each
other and then i realized just like any
kind of great technological advancement
it's a tool it's a weapon it's a sword
and it has blades that go both ways and
just like it has the potential to help
people it has the potential to hurt a
lot of people and now we're seeing a
huge backswing i remember i remember
warning about this all the way back in
2008 i have we are change videos on my
channel warning in 2008 saying hey
they're they're already starting to turn
turn on the boilers the water is
starting to get warm here and there and
look what they did here they did it very
methodically they did it very slowly
they didn't just ban everyone all at
once they started starting to actually
now now oh no
we're seeing the first bubbles in that
pot now
we're starting to turn a little bit of a
different color it's too late yeah
here's what here's what here's what i
want y'all to understand what twitter is
doing what facebook is doing and youtube
is doing is actually diminishing their
ability to control anything and will
result in substantial chaos if there are
100 people in a room and you have rules
and some of those people break the rules
then you can slowly start to remove some
of those people or you can compromise
and say here's what we'll accept and
here's what we won't
and what happens is
if you decide to ban 10 people now you
have 10 people in one room and 90 in the
other and you have no say of what those
10 people are doing
we're going to come to the point where
twitter has half of the people in one
room and half in the other and then it's
going to be two equal sized rooms with
no control over the other side no
ability to influence or de-radicalize or
communicate at all and that's when the
clash happens and the chilling effect
you're talking about friends who are
just deleting all their posts because
they're scared they're going to get
banned now
and i mean
the the the psychological impact that it
has just on the people who are allowed
to be there and snowden has brought this
up with you know how surveillance
impacts your your your brain and how you
want to communicate he said today is a
major turning point in history that says
yeah go ahead sorry no yeah but it's
just the the chilling effect and the
the mass
sort of social
psychological implications that this has
like in in in the herd mentality when
everybody's posting like either in
support of it or against it but like at
the end of the day all that matters is
data what actually works and they're not
published
they know this
they have to be able to see that what
they're doing is making things worse and
they they have to know this
there's no way
they've seen it before they've banned
people before they've seen the reaction
and they have to
you know what it is maybe they don't
have the data from external platforms
but i'll tell you this anyone with a
brain can take a look at the bannings
they did and then the chaos that ensued
yesterday and be like hey remember two
years ago when you banned all these
people how did that work for you now
they're on parlor and you have no
control at all you've given it up you've
said go do your thing
they could have compromised yeah well
now well now we have the next level of
how uh insane this gets confirmation
from axios google suspends parlor from
app store after deadly capital violence
this is not gonna stop it
it's it's a simple apk download okay
google takes it out of the play store
and then they put it up on their website
so when you open your phone and you go
to parlor.com eventually at some point i
assume it'll say download the apk you'll
click it boom you got it what does
removing it from the play store do it
slows things down significantly i mean
we were suspended from
google play and app store for like six
months yeah so you go to mines.com
mobile and get the mobile app now you
can get the apk or you get us in the app
stores but like you know that hurt us
and it it will hurt parlor and you know
that it's
and the thing is that it's become too
polarized it's like the left you know
twitter the left-wing social network
parlor the right-wing social network
it's like
it it need we need from a high level at
the companies to be having serious
conversations live streaming
and saying how are we going to bring
this community together how are we going
to deal with these people or nationalize
social media or a globalized one one
that follows the us constitution that we
create i mean it will be globalized it
can be anybody in the world we can use
it and it will follow the us
constitution yes
i don't think they would ever and an app
we need a website social network that
does it and we need
um an isp that follows the us
constitution that's not a private
company so let me read a little bit of
this they say quote in order to protect
user safety on google play our
long-standing policies require that apps
displaying user-generated content have
moderation policies and enforcement that
removes egregious content like posts
that incite violence jose castaneda a
google spokesperson said in light of
this ongoing and urgent public safety
threat we are suspending the apps
listing from the play store until it
addresses these issues what does that
mean
uh
you're not allowed to incite violence on
parlor they'll ban you for it
no joke in fact parlor's got very strict
rules my understanding is that they they
operate on what's called a broadcast
standard meaning you actually can't like
you can't say certain things that are
free speech and that's that's the way
they run their platform i mean it's it's
a gab 2.0 situation basically and and
the problem you know
free speech policies every network
should have but like the fact that there
there's you know there are privacy
issues and transparency issues with
parlor i'm just gonna you know be
upfront about that like their code is
not open source you can't see their
algorithms if you're listening guys open
source your code like
networks have to be open source
otherwise it's not viable in the long
term i think uh
the i don't know if the fetaverse is the
answer we've talked about it before but
some kind of decentralized federated
social network
the way it would work it's very simple
is how the federal rest works is that
you don't have to use parlor you would
use just you know fetiverse apps a
regular old app you download and then
you you sign in to your server or their
server or whatever server and it
connects all the different companies
into one social media system yeah the
fetiverse is great it's the activity pub
protocol which mastodon uses
which um
many sites are integrating there's
another another one polaroma we're
working on activity pub integration been
it's taken way too long for us to do it
but
it's a great protocol the problem the
problem with it though is that when you
subscribe to someone on another node
you the comment threads don't work right
it's just like it's so it's sort of
messy it's still good and it's a step in
the right direction but it's not truly
decentralized social media because you
know the admins can still ban the whole
you know the note yeah they can cut off
like if there was a networked you know
gab connected to mines you know one
platform could cut off the other
platform right yeah well
the idea is is preliminary i suppose but
how do we get to the point where if i
choose to follow the president for his
updates no one can take that away ever i
think they call internet 2.0 the tron
network was working on something like
that well that's what we integrated with
with the perma web with the r-weave
blockchain basically
you have the option when you post to
post to the perma web you know obviously
you don't want every post to be
permanent but the reality is that we're
moving into a blockchain decentralized
world and that that is a little bit
scary
but ethereum is going to skyrocket
ethereum yeah i just bought something
32. exposure but uh you you bring up a
blockchain i think what a lot of people
need to realize is that a lot of these
networks that use crypto they're built
off of the ethereum cryptocurrency and
there are some other amazing
decentralized social networks like
scuttlebutt is fully decentralized it's
sort of like techy and and
tough to use but it's it is fully
decentralized so it's on your machine
everything
um
yeah so regarding the r weave network if
you were to post something um on the are
we blockchain and then you owned that
post and it was there forever could it
then generate crypto tokens for every
view that it accrued that's not how
their system works but
i mean theoretically you could build
whatever you want i remember at burning
man some people started to do
peer-to-peer
uh bluetooth communications um yeah uh
i was on a cruise and they told everyone
when you come on to download this app i
if what it was called but you turn on
bluetooth and then this is the craziest
thing
you can walk past one person and all the
data is being transmitted from like my
app to their app and then when they walk
past another person it bounces to like
five more people and then created this
mesh internet where if i was standing 10
feet from you you were 10 feet from me
and ian was 10 feet from you know you
know bob smith and then bob smith sent a
message it would relay through everyone
to me yeah local networks that's amazing
that that's really important for
countries that don't have serious
infrastructure yeah well uh also in the
united kingdom when rock and roll was
banned what they started to do is
literal pirate ships they had ships that
would broadcast
uh rock and roll oh i saw that movie and
yeah radio there's you know there's
whole movies about this you know
censorship throughout history is
something that is more common than not
than uncommon so we have to understand
uh you know this is a going towards a
trend that that i don't want to be on
well so here's what's going to happen
the the left controls the cultural
institutions so a political coup in my
opinion is totally meaningless it is
what we're seeing right now is
actually i'll step back as they say
politics downstream from culture
by getting rid of all of the voices that
can you know propagate certain ideas
those ideas cease to exist that's it
they're gone they've been slowly and
methodically removing certain ideas and
certain people from these platforms and
they've been doing it for a very long
time and i remember they were doing it
to individuals that i didn't like i
didn't agree with i didn't identify with
i was like yeah i don't like these guys
too
but
but i don't think their voice should be
censored and i've been saying that
consistently from the very beginning but
they used our own fears our own emotions
against us to justify it slowly and
surely and now we're here today i think
the argument is it can't be stopped like
it is downstream from culture and the
technology so we need a technological
revolution that will prevent anyone from
being able to do that it is happening
but that's why it's crazy bitcoin's
hitting all-time highs today i mean that
is the decentralized infrastructure for
the new
system
yeah it's incredible what is it what
does a bitcoin get you in terms of that
system though like bitcoin can't do you
can do things on top of bitcoin as well
there are projects that are trying to
build
layer two solutions on top of different
blockchains this is the thing it's an
encryption peer-to-peer
technology and it's it's something new
like the printing press so when the
printing press came out everyone in the
beginning was like oh this is nothing
this is an old machine this is not going
to do anything but but it revolutionized
the way people gathered information
bitcoin is revolutionizing the way
people transact and just like the
internet double-edged sword could go
either way could go towards the total
venezuelan russian cryptocurrency track
tracing database system or it could go
towards a decentralization liberty
sovereignty freedom uh technology that
helps people be individuals helps people
be secure and most most importantly
helps people be private let me tell you
about the radicalization of the left in
this country
in 2016 i did an interview with oliver
darcy when he was working at business
insider he's now at cnn on reliable
sources
the interview was because i tweeted out
defense of alt-right white nationalists
who were being removed from twitter now
these people weren't saying you know
inciting violence these were people who
were posting nasty opinions i didn't
like these are people who don't like me
at all because of who my my because of
my family's you know regional heritage
i'll put it that way and so oliver darcy
asked me like what are you what are your
thoughts on it it's a slippery slope you
start removing people because you like
these ideas then eventually they're
banning the left that was oliver darcy
recently for the past day or so he
advocated for cable providers to ban fox
news oan and newsmax because they spread
lies
talk about a dramatic change from where
he was only four or so years ago when he
was interviewing me because he thought
it was newsworthy i said we must have
free speech even for those we don't like
i am still standing here on the same
hill saying we must have free speech for
those we don't like otherwise you create
conflict and he now has gone so far that
not only is he advocating for the
removal of entire cable channels he's
contacting a t and verizon and comcast
and saying
will you remove them you're responsible
etc you're allowed to spread lies in the
united states well it's protected again
that's still absolutely unhinged
dangerous behavior that corporations who
want more power with little fleeing
individuals coming to them coming to
them saying please take away all my
rights take away everything take away
the most important right of what my ears
could listen to of course they're going
to be like yes give it to me i'll be
your overlord daddy come on here and
again we've seen this coming for a long
time one of the major criticisms against
donald trump within the last few years
is that he's not making a stand against
free speech he's not making a stand
against the first amendment many of his
critics what do you mean stand against
do you mean standing up for standing up
for the first amendment standing up for
free speech and and it's interesting to
see laura loomer tweet this out today
she said according to a telegram post at
least trump can still order a sandwich
on uber eats though for now i can't say
the same sadly so again this has been
happening to a lot of his core
supporters we you know again and you
know you know you know the interesting
laura loomer was was beyond the canary
in the coal mine i mean this was like
someone yelling the the coal mine is
full of carbon monoxide get out now and
the republicans weren't smart enough to
to push through legislation while they
had the chance so did loomer get taken
off the stripe or the uh the this was it
the swift payment system she got banned
from the global payments you love the
swift i don't know i don't i don't i
have never heard anything about it swift
is like the
level yes yes i get it i guess
but what when did you ever hear anything
like that no why can't she use money
what do you mean what are you talking
about laura loomer uber eats she's super
amazing
you can't get banned from not her
finances no she was she was banned i
believe from those platforms as well but
not swift that is nothing are you sure
you can't be put on a black list of
swifter you probably probably i mean
mastercard reached out to patreon over
this guy what was his name robert
spencer i think so yeah he yeah
spencer
yeah uh what it was the wrong spencer it
wasn't richard spencer no robert
robertson yes and and when you mean the
wrong spencer he was the person they
were targeting on purpose he's he writes
about oh that's right that's right he
writes about radical islam and
mastercard got angry and said to patreon
remove him otherwise we'll cut off
services i think mastercard was forced
to do that by swift i could be wrong
about that i mean this is actually a
historic day yeah i think we actually
have to zoom out and let it sink in for
a second yeah this is the corporate
takeover of i mean the corporate this
proves corporations have more power than
the government that's right
corporations have just removed the
speech of the sitting u s president yep
michael michael tracy has a comment here
that i think is really timely he says
quote corporate left liberals are
desperate for revenge they will use all
powers at their disposal public and
private to neutralize their purported
insurrectionist enemies and they
absolutely do not care one bit what
civil liberties are destroyed in the
process
divisive i don't want to say this is
it's not though it's way more than two
sides it's it's a bunch of people with a
bunch of different ideas
but it is very frustrating that trump
didn't facilitate a
cross-spectrum conversation more
directly like he had the opportunity
yeah and it seems like he really did not
bring the people bill you and i were in
the white house at the social media
event yeah you're the ceo of a company
he could be using and someone said will
you just use another platform he says
which one which one i don't know donald
trump and joe biden and all the
progressives both sides we have to
constantly be disclaiming that we need
both sides yes there's no network
without you consider using minds tech
for a government program that we could
yeah they can use it hey call me up
government yeah
i mean make your own yeah social network
with the mind software that could
integrate with
my the minds node is a proof of
absolutely
i mean the government just just um
okayed banks running bitcoin and
ethereum nodes which is a very big deal
what we're seeing unfortunately is
tribal divide there's not just two
factions there's hundreds and probably
thousands but there are two overarching
parent factions of these these
overarching parent factions we just
typically refer to them as left and
right but that means very little for
instance how is it that tim poole who's
economically left and even socially left
is considered right-wing because i
believe in freedom free speech liberty
principles integrity etc that is not
something that exists for the most part
among the left what the left believes in
is for one what did we see from cuomo on
cnn during the riots he said who says
protesters have to have to be peaceful
right and then ramen guy comes out and
says it's right there in the first
amendment mr como he's got to look it up
then then you get jake tapper and cnn
saying oh i can't believe what they're
doing
when the riots happened i said those
riots are bad when the riots the
capitals happened i said those riots are
bad there is principle and i'm not
saying everybody on the right has it i'm
saying
it's not something typically of the left
it is a tendency i can't take the right
and the left stuff dude the chinese the
chinese used the rightists this was the
com mao's communist takeover was against
the rightists they focused on dividing
people into these camps and then
targeted use them against each other but
what you need to understand is the
divide is a real thing well not made up
by someone's talking any fractionalized
divide of many millions of different
concepts at once and to just think that
we're in different camps of of types is
crazy conservatives right now calling
for the removal of their political
opponents from major players it's not a
conservative move it's a very liberal
move exactly and it's only coming from
what we colloquially refer to as the
right there are some on the left
liberals and progressives people like
glenn greenwald but now they call him
alt-right and matt tybee and michael
tracy who does i don't th there's
there's there are two tribes you can
call them tribes a and b one or two it
doesn't matter where are these two
they're the overarching parents to
numerous other tribes you have to use
words ian yeah i will and is it because
there's democrat and republican two
power parties so we say then there's
left and there's right two it's a
reference to the french revolution to
those who sit on the left and those who
set on the right and those on the right
were you know moderates and those on the
left were radicals who wanted revolution
i think it's so dangerous to get into
that mind well using more specific
language is actually i'm not going to
sit here and say the socialists the
anarchists the communists the tanks
no blame their group for what they did
if someone does something they're
responsible for that it is a tendency
among all of the factions on both sides
to hold certain ideals and principles
they don't completely agree with each
other left fights themselves all the
time on the right you have people who
are awful and white nationalists who
would defend donald trump and the left
doesn't but that is not the over
overwhelmingly
that's not overwhelmingly the majority
or even a large portion of what the
right represents in fact the alt-right
and the white nationalists actually
agree with the left and a ton of
left-wing policy issues the point is
when it comes to the cultural debate
there are two apparent factions fine we
won't say left and right we'll say one
and two you're not one or two dude i
know
yeah right there's more than one and two
or three but pragmatically ian you have
to use words in order to have a
conversation it's like saying but just
are you going to vote republican or
democrat this time well that yeah
absolutely you should be talking about
all the options there's some initial
reports i haven't been able to
independently verify this but we're
hearing that president donald trump was
trying to use the potus account and that
he was tweeting from it but twitter
removed the tweet instantaneously that
it happened again that's just some of
the reports that are coming in right now
from the at potus account now the potus
account is still active the latest
allegations and reports that are coming
in now that i have not verified is that
he did tweet and it was deleted by
twitter that would be a shadow now so
that's what i'm hearing right now
um is happening who's who's reporting it
though uh anybody just had it here i
just
went up here i already saw like three
people tweet it
um well we'll search for it and we'll
see what we can find so he's been seeing
people reportedly shadow band on his
other account
well it's not his account it's our
account yes we have images here josh
kaplan verified twitter user he is a
homepage editor for breitbart news
tweets twitter deletes series of tweets
presumably written by president trump on
the potus account following the
permanent ban of his account wow he
tweeted 8 29 pm today as i've been
saying for a long time twitter has gone
further and further in banning free
speech and tonight twitter employees
have coordinated with the democrats and
the radical left in removing my account
from their platform to silence me and
you the 75 million great
patriots who voted for me twitter may be
a private company but without the
government's gift of section 230 they
would not exist for long i predicted
this would happen
we have been negotiating with various
other sites and i will have a big
announcement soon while we also look at
the possibilities of building our own
building out our own platform the near
future we will not be silenced twitter
is not about free speech they are all
about promoting a radical left platform
where some of the most vicious people in
the world are allowed to speak freely
stay tuned
this did come from the president to the
potus account and it has been removed
and another thing that we're hearing is
that he might give a publicly televised
address soon but the thing is who's
going to hear it because when we saw
during the election many news
organizations just cut him out they said
no we're not going to play the
president's address we're just going to
stop it here what the president is
saying is wrong we don't agree with it
and there is huge editorializing even on
fox news
interrupting the president saying no
this is one reason second reason third
reason why the president is wrong what's
going to happen if he does a national
address now
i mean i'll tell you when i hear it i'll
tell you you know you know what i'm
worried about
before the mass purge they just pulled
off
i think many people were willing to
accept that trump had finally been
defeated mike cernovich for instance one
of the most prominent trump supporters
ever seen in the trump era
he put up a poll and he said did donald
trump concede yes no
unsure show me the results something
like that and around 25
said no
donald trump made a video where he said
there will be a new administration and
we will peacefully transition i made a
video trump confirms defeat mike pence
certifies joe biden trump said it i
don't know what i was supposed to take
from that
but many trump supporters around 25 of
mike cernovich's you know polled said he
didn't concede mike responded by saying
to those who believe this i love you
please un unfollow people who have made
you believe this go home to your loved
ones they miss you
and you know it's time to stop
essentially i'm paraphrasing he's right
there are people who are ardent and
prominent trump supporters who are
saying guys please please enough okay
trump has said he's lost it's over then
they do this
then twitter comes out and does this and
they do more and they do more now
they're purging people left and right
and i think many of those people who are
probably like yeah you know i was
probably dom at the capitol i guess it's
over now they're enraged now they're
angry you you took like it's like here's
how i imagine it you've got a guy in a
bar right
and he's he's disparaging you and then
you're about to fight and then he goes
you know what you know what i'm not
doing this i'm out of here he turns
around and walks away so you throw a can
at his head and then he turns around and
says that's it that's what we had people
were right not everybody was walking
away for sure a lot of people were
saying crazy things but a lot of people
were like all right all right walking
away and then twitter was like not yet
whipped them in the head and then they
turned around and now i think they're
going to explode and now my concern is
after seeing this
there is real fear about multinational
corporations shutting down the president
it should not be allowed in my opinion
by u.s law
that our executive or chief executive
could be shut down on a major
communication platform that has
essentially seized the commons
in terms of communication this is a
major power grab we have to understand
historically when an entity or a force
go after power and they get it they go
after more you know there's an
expression if you give your pinky you're
going to give up your whole hand
eventually
exactly so so this is a slippery slope
this is the snowball that's been
happening ever since 2008
and it's been snowballing and it's
getting big and it's only going to get
bigger because who's going to stand in
the way who's going to promote free
speech who's going to uphold it who's
going to protect it what institutions
are out there that could actually make a
stand here i don't see fox news doing
that at all i don't see any other
website all of the means of
communication have been hijacked
and are in the hands of special
interests and a few people is there any
hope guys
let me tell you something when trump won
there were a lot of trump supporters
being mean and snide and mocking and
belittling as people screamed and cried
and memes went crazy
and now we're seeing the same we're
saying a lot of the same on the other
side but now it's not coming from random
people on the internet it's coming from
cnn
we have asha rengappa
she is i'm pretty sure let me make sure
yes fbi uh former fbi special eight
special agent and cnn analyst said i'm
not even going to screenshot what he's
tweeting from the potus account
twitter's already taking it down but boo
boo mad
this is the kind of dismissive and
insulting and humiliating humiliating
content coming from prominent
institutions which will trigger mass
rage
i don't care
if random twitter user123
tweets nasty things at me i don't care i
don't know who you are
i don't care to make youtube videos
about random twitter users who say dumb
things
but when it's someone who works for a
major cultural institution or polit or
politics and they have power and
influence i think it needs to be talked
about and called out they disagree and
the funny thing is this is actually a
left-wing principle they say don't punch
down
then why is it that mainstream media is
punching down calling regular americans
stupid mocking the way they live mocking
the way they work mocking their lives
now i get it mocking the president is
not punching down by all means mock him
my concern is when cnn comes out and
attacks the people who are angry
you can't also another thing you can't
really fight fascism with fascism like
that's something also a lot of people
need to realize here you can
except those who don't like fascism are
going to be really angry about it you're
going to get fascism but right right
listen if authoritarian leftists want
authoritarianism and they just don't
want authoritarian rights to win well
then there you go i don't think
orthogonalism is the best i don't think
a lot of people realize the larger kind
of implications here i don't think a lot
of people realize uh where this is going
and the historical president that this
is setting as well so augmented way you
said luke you can fight fascism with
fascism but you can't defeat fascism
with fascism yes
you can fight fashion with if
in a fascism fight all you'll get is
fascism
so to talk a little bit about the fact
checking strike quote-unquote
fact-checking strategies at facebook and
twitter like what they're doing is
basically bringing in a small group of
think tanks and it's it's it's it's not
a real system so what we're actually
talking about doing is working with uh
this group ground.news i don't know if
you've ever heard of them they for every
article they their algorithm grabs all
the articles and shows on both sides and
they sort of are doing the best it seems
good faith effort to show all the
coverage on both sides and so
that when you're scrolling down your
feed you can get context
to
what you're seeing and i you know that's
where we need to be going giving people
access to all of the data around
the post so that they have the most
information not just saying this is true
or this is false facebook knew what they
were doing
facebook knew early on that they were
feeding ex you know hyper partisan
content to different sides in fact there
are some news organizations that knew
this too and created two different
versions of their content
because one would feed to the left and
one would feed to the right and there
was a thing they would do it's just
general journalism a b testing where
they'll write an article and in some
regions they would use certain titles
different in other regions total
different framing to see how it would
perform to maximize the amount of ads
they would get the amount of clicks they
would get and in turn the revenue
because they knew that somebody who
lived in texas
would probably see you know rather see
an article that says nancy pelosi is bad
and the people lived in san francisco
probably would like to see nancy pelosi
good they were doing like experiments on
users facebook oh yes where they would
feed them emotionally charged uh
articles to see if it would produce more
clicks
now they've got uh
you know artificial intelligence or
whatever this this algorithm is that's
private you know tweaking and deciding
what people see and what what gets
flagged so i'll tell you you know what
you know who our government really is
it's the robots it's whose controls the
narrative yeah it's well what is the
thing to govern is the control the mind
control of the system right now if
if facebook uses an ai to feed content
to people
it might be on
speaking colloquially facebook creates
an algorithm that feeds certain content
all that matters is
this what i've said jack dorsey has
swallowed so much of his own refuse i
think he's actually been radicalized by
what he's created
i i've if you look at him compared to
where he was when twitter launched to
where he is now he's a dramatically
different person and why does he believe
the things he believes he created a
platform that incentivizes rage content
and then he started eating that content
which changed his brain and then he had
the keys to the castle went in and
changed more of the platform to keep
feeding into that it's an insanity loop
if if
he created it
it radicalized him and then he sold it
and then he made it crazier and crazier
to fit his new radicalized mind
think about what he said in the
beginning with a free speech wing of the
free speech party but that was just a
joke think about what i said to him when
i said your misgendering rule is
ideological because conservatives don't
don't
understand that view they have a totally
different worldview but he couldn't see
it because he had been swimming in the
refuse he created yep and he didn't just
create it he made the world crazier in
the instant that you brought it up but
also another aspect to understand here
mental health has been in decline ever
since we saw the rise of social media
many people say that is a massive
correlation that's another way that it
impact people with depression suicides
and a lot of other mental health defects
that are skyrocketing right now as we're
speaking so so if you go out you know on
an average day if you talk to a neighbor
or if you talk to a stranger
they're not as crazy as they are online
you will talk to a random person about
that you have a lot more in common you
used to but now it's becoming less and
less rare but
more on average more on average if you
go out there if you talk to your
neighbor you're more likely to get along
with them than not the world is not as
crazy and it was purported but the
reporting of it as being as crazy makes
it crazy i i think that's how it used to
be i think you i think you're wrong now
i think this the the radicalization of
social media has now led to people just
outside at random being tribalized and
radicalized and
and not to mention people will barely
talk to each other because they have a
mask on their face and it's like a whole
other level of isolation in your own
house so even if you're not on on social
media
you're not you're not going everybody
comes over
is he going to shake my hand am i
allowed to touch this guy's hand right
it's so weird or think about when you're
in uh when you're when you're in a city
where there's a political event going on
and they think you look like a trump
supporter or they think you look like
antifa
you know where can you walk based on how
you how you appear imagine walking
around new york city wearing actually
people have done this walk around l.a
wearing a maga hat see what happens
blair white did it she got attacked i
would say a fingernail ripped off a lot
of the chaos today and the mental health
issues comes from text and trust people
attempting to communicate through text
which is a new form of communication
with humans they used to send letters
before that before
you know written language they all
communicated with with words and sounds
and and we've lost so much touch of our
ability to communicate with our words i
find i have so much um
you know faith and and love for people
that make internet video because you
speak your mind with your words and your
sound and your vibration and it's
completely different than etching
something onto a stone for someone else
to attempt to interpret it
but but even
like this is one of the reasons we don't
do skype here and we never first of all
we're not set up for it there could be
maybe some exception in the future but
we don't because it doesn't work even
hearing their voice you got to see their
face you have to be able to i i
interrupted you ian were you know what i
mean i did i did notice that yeah to
jump in and make that point good that's
what we're supposed to do you can't do
that on a zoom in text it wouldn't work
because the digital overlap a lot of
times there's a problem the time delays
and the the awkwardness of you know
you're staring at a camera you're not
staying at a screen you don't see their
face people don't realize that they
think when you're when you're doing a
skype debate or a zoom call that you can
see each other's face and look into each
other's eyes
no you have a camera when i go when i
when i would do a fox news or say in the
past when i did go on msnbc
or some of these other networks i'm
staring into a black hole that's it i
don't see myself i don't see them and
you know the worst thing about these
cable networks is you can never hear
anything they give you there's a delay
yeah you get an earpiece you get an
earpiece and it's so quiet you're like
can you turn it up i can't hear anything
and then they're like uh so we're gonna
go live
the producer's always allowed we're
gonna go live in about 10 seconds and
then you hear the husk
[Music]
and i'm like dude i can't hear you okay
you're ready to talk okay
you need to be sitting down with someone
to have a real meaningful conversation
but at the same time we're seeing all
the news networks now are doing remote
video chats and like i agree with you
it's not as good but i mean to ian's
point
a video message is more effective or a
phone call compared to a text text
message is dangerous you cannot get them
people freak out because they over
interpret what they're doing like
sarcasm is completely lost in time well
even just like in relationships and like
people like people's girlfriends
send them messages like oh my god dude
and we live in this world of it now
that's that's radicalizing and making
people insane it's it's i don't know how
to how to overemphasize how dangerous it
is to communicate with text
and rely on it as your form of
communication
we're vibrating
monkey bodies that speak words for a
reason
i think text is a great way to relay
information text was a revolution but
not to communicate
feelings
it is yeah it is it can be it can be but
it's it it depends on the context i
think that if i wanna i can write
something with a feeling in it but if
you read it you're gonna interpret your
own feeling but if i
say something to you with a feeling
you're gonna feel what i'm feeling i
wanna i wanna i was gonna pull up a
tweet based on what you said i tweeted
this
if history has taught us anything it's
that you should trust the government in
times of emergency to do what's right
keep us well informed as the ongoing
legitimacy of the threat and give up
emergency powers once the crisis is
averted
i intentionally just said it but it it i
call it a filter i call tweets like that
a filter clearly to anybody who is
hearing me talk if i was to say this in
real life
i would say something like if history
has taught us anything it's that you
should trust the government in times of
emergency to do what's right keep us
well informed of the ongoing legitimacy
of the threat and to give up emergency
powers once the crisis is averted
clearly knowing i'm being facetious in a
tweet people thought it was real now
most people retweeted it laughing they
understood the context tim's being
sarcastic facetious et cetera but a lot
of people saw that and they were like
dude what is wrong with you and those
people can become crazy dangerous if
they don't understand that's i i have i
have a friend who's a prominent leftist
who told me that people don't understand
my tweets are jokes
and i'm like what am i supposed to do
when i say something so absurd and
ridiculous
like uh i i
i have another one put a smiley face at
the end i said or a goofy face yeah
that's all you gotta do so you know what
i do now is i actually reply with hello
you must be new to twitter this is a
joke i'm not serious
i said the good news is now that now
with democrats in full control we can
finally lock down the country for a
couple of years to make sure covet goes
away and a lot of people are like what
are you crazy what's wrong some people
really think that stuff they believe it
right they'll tweet that out seriously
so people are like is he has he switched
has he has he changed
dude what ryan long just tweeted the
funniest thing not that i you know what
did you want to be looking at twitter
right now but
jack dorsey just yelled i'm a golden god
before jumping into his pool
yeah what's so there's this phenomenon
where you can sell your company that's
kind of a problem you create this
phenomenon like twitter jack did and
then he sold it he owns like six percent
of it now he gave up power gave up
control um yeah google was started by
larry and sergey they've become monsters
they're gone they're not even part of
the company anymore as far as i know
well they're alphabet yeah well i don't
you said they were even off the board of
alphabet i heard that really yeah maybe
confirm but they they silently stepped
away and the odd thing to me about
dorsey is that he's all about bitcoin
he's tweeting about signal which is
actually a great open source you know
elon was tweeting about signal the other
day like amazing project that was signal
that was was that moxie marlon spike
yeah interesting yeah yeah and and so
it's like he's aware of this but for
some reason the speech thing
he doesn't get
dorsey darcy why does he care about
bitcoin and signal is he really in
charge he's not i don't think so i think
he's a figurehead and yeah so he got
fired a long time ago and they brought
on dick costolo and then when he left i
can't remember why i think he may have
been fired dorsey became the ceo i think
it was costolo maybe i'm getting my
people mixed up and uh dorsey
i think is was just brought on to appear
to be in in control and really he's not
i don't think he is i think he owns 66
yeah well one another thing to really
kind of consider here when you look at a
lot of the big tech companies they
either have direct involvement with the
startup
of them and intelligence agencies or
they have ongoing contracts and
cooperations with continued government
agencies that they are working
hand-in-hand with case and point amazon
and the cia and the department
department of defense
facebook and uh for was that startup
connected to the intelligence agency uh
that was integral on their start we have
google and of course uh google maps uh
working with of course the us pentagon
to make that happen and there was
another one uh inquitel i think no i
don't i don't know that's a lot of
faction we have to do for a lot of yeah
i'm gonna have to look into that stuff
to be to talk more clearly on it let's
talk let's talk about the real yeah this
says dorsey owns two percent of
twitter's outstanding shares wow does
that mean total stock outstanding
insurance worth 531 million two percent
two he's not involved at all in that
company he runs square he's square
he splits he's two he's a ceo of both
right yeah but i think he's just 13 i
think ceo
oh really yeah so he really he might be
ceo and title but that doesn't mean he
runs the country right yeah well let's
talk about
where the escalation has brought us from
fox 4
josh hawley speaks out arguing biden
called him a nazi when talking to
reporters
you senator hawley fired back friday
saying president-elect joe biden
compared him to a nazi propagandist he
didn't say he did joe biden did from
the dallas news joe biden likens ted
cruz to nazi propagandist goebbels for
helping trump spread big lie about
election fraud it wasn't just cruz it
was also josh hawley
now holly's firing back saying
president-elect biden has just compared
me and another republican senator to
nazis think about that for a moment let
that sink in
hawley argued he raised lawful questions
about the way elections were conducted
just as democrats did in previous years
but saw a much different outcome this is
undignified immature and intemperate
behavior from the president-elect it is
utterly shameful he should act like a
dignified adult and retract these sick
comments the president-elect made the
comments while answering reporters
questions in washington dc friday
afternoon a reporter asked biden if
senators holly and cruz should resign
after a violent mob contesting the
election results stormed the capital
biden said the two senators should be
flat beaten in their next elections
biden then referred to the big lie and
said that those like goebbels holly and
cruz kept repeating the lie goebbels was
a member of the nazi party and a reich
minister of propaganda under adolf
hitler during world war ii it's exactly
the kind of rhetoric everybody would
want to hear from the incoming
president-elect right the one who's
calling for unity no
this is this is
a level of depravity and insanity i'm so
what should he do in his last few weeks
trump yeah a few days a few days two
days sorry i mean he's there i don't
know but there they said they're going
to impeach him on monday
the democrats are going to impeach him i
don't know if he'll get removed because
if republicans and democrats split 50 50
then mike pence breaks the tie but what
if mitch mcconnell says yeah i'll break
the tie and he decides trump trump's
calling oh
you know and then he and then he votes
them out we're gonna get any
declassified files no i don't think so
i don't trump has been unable to get
anything declassified they don't listen
to him he's talking about firing people
i don't know what he's gonna do but
listen
you know i was mentioning this earlier
when you have
the people who are willing to walk away
kind of conceding with their tail
between their legs and then you throw
something in the back of their head
this from joe biden is like they're
pouring fuel on the fire why
why would he say this about these
senators why would why would he tell
look it was over right right right yeah
it's done
and i'll tell you what's really crazy
about the scenario what ted cruz and
josh hawley did was entirely
constitutional yeah they were allowed to
do it it was not out of the ordinary
it's happened before it happened 2005 it
happened a bunch of times i mean 2016
was crazy
and the end result would have been biden
getting certified as president it would
have given trump supporters their voice
in on on the electoral college count
floor it would have satisfied many not
all to be like well at least the
american people can hear what we have to
say and we weren't denied that
opportunity now unfortunately it was the
trump supporters who stormed in and
stopped that from happening
but to criticize josh hawley and ted
cruz as though they're nazi
propagandists or and in any way like him
simply because they wanted to say here's
what's happening and here's why we have
concerns about this
that's that i think that should be
evidence
that people don't want unity and that
this is likely going to escalate and
escalate faster than you realize it
reminds me about what the nazis did
because they would demonize the the
communists and then
so he's like we need a new national
crackdown on terrorism those people are
acting like the nazi party from old it's
like that's what the nazis did to the
communists they cracked down and they
said that they were the evil from you
know the ten years ago in russia or
whatever i'm starting now the first
sentence is you're a nazi the second
sentence is unity everyone come together
like
really are you are you really trying to
act like you're you're bringing people
together if you're using hyperbolic
language like that well so you we have
had for years people tweeting things
about killing nazis and punching them
but then they go and call literally
everyone nazis or compare everyone to
nazis and so
what are people supposed to think you
want to hurt us you want to attack us
because it's not about attacking nazis
it's about using the worst possible
smear you can against those you don't
agree with that way when you advocate
for some like listen there are people on
twitter who are saying you know kill
nazis or whatever
twitter allows it
then once that's been approved they then
tack onto it here's a list of who the
nazis are and they grab random people
they don't like and now twitter's
approved that
so i'll tell you when when joe biden
says that he says the the protesters are
domestic terrorists those that storm the
capital he says these these senators are
basically propagandists for the
insurrection
the wall street journal reports mr biden
has said he he plans to make a priority
of pas of a law a passing a law against
domestic terrorism and he has been and
he has been urged to create a white
house post overseeing the fight against
ideological inspired violent extremists
and increasing funding to combat them
who is it called the enabling act
yeah you know what i said it's gonna be
called like the safe act like securing
american freedoms you know enhanced
the safe act for everybody start a new
so this is like another homeland
security advise them come on who is the
establishment yeah exactly who did do we
have ideas of who is in his ear right
now he's in his ear he's an
establishment a candidate he's got the
lobbyists and he's going
what they're probably thinking these
establishment people is once we get
power we better make sure these people
never win again and he's not just
talking about trump he's talking about
bernie sanders too and that's why i
think it's hilarious many of these left
just walked right into this it should
have been obvious i said it if if the
establishment gets back in they're going
to lock the doors and no populist will
ever see it whether it's left or right
yeah they would do the same thing to
cortez i would think
um is trying to play the game right now
calling for people's censorship another
scary aspect of this is that you know
biden he kind of showed that he's not
really there he he's he's not on it he
doesn't have the ball
in front of him it looks like someone
else has the ball and is carrying this
whole program here when you look at his
speech when you look at his mindset um
competent doesn't come to mind and when
you have that you also understand that
this is the person that sold out to the
special interest almost more than any
other president before him he argued
with barack obama saying that there
needs to be more special interest inside
of the obama administration and obama
had to tell him no so when we have big
tech executives inside of the biden
administration goldman sachs the
military industrial complex and you have
unlimited power you look at that entire
recipe there's no one or nothing that
could check him another thing that i
kind of wanted to bring up is that if if
you remember chuck schumer literally
brought up that if you mess with the i
this is not his exact phrase but he said
when donald trump messes with the
intelligence agencies they have six ways
to sunday to get back at him
so i also in relation to that i also
want to bring up this cb cbs news
article that is literally titled social
media is a tool of the cia seriously
that is the title of their article on
cbs news and they start off by saying
quote you don't need to wear tin foil
hat to believe that the cia is using
facebook twitter google and other social
media companies to spy on people that's
because the cia published a helpful list
of press releases on all the social
media ventures it sponsors
via its technology investment firm
in qtel so again that's that's the firm
that i brought up here previously before
so there is a lot of things to talk
about there there's a lot of room for
kind of speculation here even though i
don't like doing that but we have to
understand when we look at these big
tech companies they're not just outside
entities outside of the government they
are entities that work with the
government hand in hand not just spying
on you but in more severe ways than we
even know and this is truly an emerging
power that that can't be unchecked at
amazon it's not considered a social
network but they have that 100 computer
that everyone's got people have in their
house that you can command and listen
well this is another thing with amazon
with amazon they're working they're
working on new
uh technology that will break encryption
they're working on oh they've got it
yeah well they do yeah they all well
quantum supremacy you know you know
about this right bill yeah but i don't
think it's it's we don't know the exact
level yeah we don't know the exact
details here they were heavily
criticized for developing facial
recognition technology that was used by
ice but that's only just the tip of the
iceberg here literally uh comparatively
to all the other big deep state projects
that they're working on that they're
developing that need to be brought up
have you seen go big show on tbs uh we
were slowly i was watching two minutes
why can't you just let them have the
power
didn't you want to see the man do the
backflip on the tricycle the man was too
busy working out there was another guy i
heard luke who got a football to the
groin
interesting yes wouldn't you much rather
just order a pizza sit back watch the
football to growing show and leave the
democrats to to have their power and
what them do they want wasn't that in
idiocracy where they had a show where
the guy was just getting getting hit in
the balls that really the show that you
were watching was there really a segment
where they had okay oh i wouldn't be
surprised i wouldn't be surprised either
yeah idiocracy man mike judge nailed it
yeah i mean to be to be honest donald
trump's in the wwe hall of fame and then
camacho the president was a wrestler so
even butt has come back i heard right
well it comes back every so often
doesn't it yeah
i think we're we're headed for dark days
man
because
what's happening is happening faster and
faster
and what we saw at the capitol was i
don't you know i think in terms of the
political ramifications it was serious
and the craziest thing is when you look
at photos and there's like there's a
photo going around a guy with zip tie
handcuffs and people are like what were
they planning on doing with that like
taking hostages and then there's a
picture of a grandma who's just like
waving a little flag and she has no idea
what's going on
it's really really weird what we're
seeing but the media is treating this
like the apocalypse it's exactly what
the left the establishment the cultural
institutions needed to take action to
start purging everybody yeah so now that
now there were reports earlier before
the show that uh steve bannon's show has
been deleted from youtube
so i think you know they said it was for
election related misinformation yeah uh
that wouldn't surprise me and there's a
very famous meme going around now that
says quote we spend 750 billion dollars
annually on defense and the center of
american government fell in two hours to
the duck dynasty and the guy in the
chewbacca bikini and they have a photo
of the you know the guys in costume you
know you know it's really funny as this
purge is going on i do think some people
are leaving twitter that they're
deactivating their accounts and they're
going to parlor because the president
has been removed but i think a lot of
people are being banned and a lot of
people are noticing i think it's
probably a lot of people purposefully
leaving i wonder if the majority is as
actual bannings but my twitter following
is like it goes down and it spikes
really high because i like i'll tweet
something and then the people who remain
will start following me but then as
people are leaving it goes down a lot of
people are down like i saw one tweet
just now sixteen thousand people
yes julian assange's uh mother just
tweeted that she lost six thousand
followers just now
this is a mass purge this can't just be
people leaving twitter is going through
networks they're probably looking at a
network and just removing them you said
they were going through rudy giuliani's
well so
there's a there's a twitter bot that
will tell you when someone in the trump
network follows or unfollows and it was
this massive lift saying rudy giuliani
unfollowed this person and this person
and just huge list of people saying rudy
giuliani unfollowed these people and i'm
like did twitter just pull up rudy
giuliani's following list and just
delete everybody he followed because
they was trying to protect people maybe
no i don't know rudy giuliani is
fighting for trump so i removed this
when i was down there in the bathroom i
just thought about that we need to break
up these corporations again this is this
monopoly on public speech and i just
don't see a value to shattering the
corporations into a bunch of proprietary
networks like why would we break
facebook into facebook prime and
instagram again that zuckerberg owns
both of the code is still so i keep
going back to the way we would break up
a social network's monopoly is by
freeing their software code after they
reach a certain level of user base and
people's argument is why would i give up
my work for all this my life's work if
i've attained 100 million followers now
i lose my code and i'm like well your
code going free doesn't mean you lose
the network you still own facebook you
still can profit off of all that
activity on facebook but the code
yeah your code should be like an idea i
think it should be open sourced and i
think if we did have open source
technology the world would be a lot
better and freer and the network effects
that you can achieve
the networks network effects and growth
you can achieve not to mention because
your community will trust you more now
because you're being transparent with
them but it's it's the reason bitcoin is
exploding right now is because it's open
there's not going to be a closed system
but i i understand that you guys view
the code as our code i think that
sometimes the code can be my code and
you're all just dirty commies who think
that and i actually believe in private
property so i disagree but in all
seriousness no i think there can be i
think a lot of things need to be open
depending on what they are probably
social media if it's something that has
a serious impact on our politics civics
then we should probably understand how
that works but if it's a proprietary
service i don't think that code should
be forced like a city they're not forced
but like it's in your interest to
do it like voting
yes absolutely how they're working why
they're working we should be able to
watch
because think about it this way if we
could see the voting counting going in
in real time and how the code worked and
then something weird happened and a vote
flipped everybody would see it
the problem i guess is that it's
connected to the internet but then
everyone's watching it you know what i
mean so i don't know there's there's
there's challenges to this it's just
accountability why can't we have
accountability we should have
accountability for
so many different things in our society
that would clear things up if you're
gonna say that there was russian
collusion with donald trump show us the
evidence it took them a while to reveal
absolutely nothing and then in the
meantime they slandered and discredited
and threw people under the the bus
including myself and we are changed
we're talking about you know the voting
that just happened be transparent do
investigations look into it show us the
evidence
again that would have proved and solved
so much angst that would have proved and
solved so much of the uncertainty and
and again when these companies make
these large decisions banning people
destroying people's voice they're doing
it in a way where there's no
accountability for that there's no way
to appeal it we don't even know why the
decision was made we don't know exactly
what even led up to it it's just a
totalitarian saying that's it i get my
way i don't even have to say why i did
what i did and that's a dangerous
unaccountable power that surely
i was i was saying this years ago is
going to be abused is being abused right
now a lot of people want to talk about
civil war and stuff
and they think the right has some
tremendous advantage because they're the
tough guys because they're the
survivalists and all that stuff but i
said listen man
they'll sever the lines of communication
in two seconds before any anything
starts and then you'll be sitting there
looking at your phone saying i wonder
what's going on the lines of
communications are being severed it's
what they're doing
yeah the zuckerberg is kind of like a
mayor of a city of a town and and right
now it's like a private town like a
mayor well it's kind of like he's more
like an internet mayor or internet
governor well have you ever seen those
old westerns where like the the guy
rides into the town and he's like it's
my time exactly sheriff you work for me
it's my town now and he owns the town so
our government is in place to make sure
that no individual owns these cities
like no one owns new york it's
controlled by all of us and i think that
facebook has gotten to the strength of
power well someone governs it that's put
into power let's be real though by us
look at look what de blasio's doing
legally look his wife's got a two
million dollar staff while the city the
way the law is built i'm just talking
about it is that
i think that facebook is powerful enough
that influential enough that we should
treat it like a city and not not a a
piece of of ownership of something that
someone can own i'm just talking about
the code he can still own the domain and
people can still use facebook and he can
have stores and everything twitter twit
twitter can be
publicly owned and open with guaranteed
rights and we don't need to worry about
making money on or they could have
utility it could still be private and
all the code could be a utility that we
could build another network that is a
utility with the same code that could
integrate with twitter
yes
and because if you shatter it into a
bunch of proprietary networks it
wouldn't stop the monopoly on the
behavior right what what i think we need
platforms that are free speech
you know open publicly owned and that's
just me look maybe i'm lefty yeah
taxpayer funded nationalized with
guaranteed rights you break the law
someone reports you it's a criminal
offense you broke the law if you say a
nasty opinion you block them and say
don't want to see it that's simple what
do you do
harassment laws apply well harassment is
a crime this is how the big networks
grew
under that premise mostly i mean their
content policies were already were
always pretty restrictive like you know
but to a certain degree they rode the
whole wave of
letting people say most of what was okay
and now they're doing the bait and
switch
yeah they sell the company that's a big
problem too is that you can make a
company make it huge and popular and
then sell it to some
totalitarian dictator and then all of a
sudden 100 million people are now being
driven by this this guy that now owns
the city basically handed the keys of
the city to this next guy so yeah i
agree i don't think that
these networks should be controlled by
the bait and switch the the even the
potential for the bait and switch
shouldn't exist yeah
and do
god no no you're not so i'm going to do
the subject yeah there's
you would just expect that
executives with billions of dollars
thousands of developers at their
disposal could come up with
realistic problems for breaking echo
chambers like okay
here's recommendations of stuff that you
might disagree with or from people from
the other side of the spectrum here's
recommendations for this here's how to
curate your algorithm so you know so
you're getting a balanced diet of
information like they just literally it
is
intentional but you know the problem
with that is for like twitter
is that if you're somebody who's like if
is a far leftist and they say why don't
you follow tim poole he's a you know
moderate individual who believes in free
speech and liberty then they're going to
start spamming me and insulting me and
it's gonna be really annoying the
problem is ultimately in the end
you have uh you have many different
kinds of people but there seems to be
two overarching kinds of people the if
someone is bothering me i'll block them
group and the if someone's bothering me
i demand twitter block them from
everyone group
and so there's no negotiating
it's one of the things that i think jack
dorsey actually said in one of his
testimony in his senate testimony he was
like we have people who are demanding on
the left that we ban people for this
reason and then the right demands that
we don't ban them for this reason and we
have to figure out like we have these
both you know both groups screaming in
our ears now i guess ultimately because
the cultural institutions and the media
are controlled by the left these big
tech companies know exactly who butters
their bread they want to sell
advertisements right well if a news
story comes out the wall street journal
that youtube does bad then youtube says
we're so sorry wall street journal
please and then they they cave
that's what happened with pewdiepie in
the first ad pocalypse
and the crazy thing is these news
outlets know youtube is their
competition so they're doing it on
purpose for probably for now for
financial gain but they also learned
that people like to hear their own
thoughts regurgitated to them so they
created echo chambers through the
algorithm and i remember back in the day
when the internet was still amazing in a
beautiful place and was a free place
because it didn't have any algorithms it
didn't have any news feeds it didn't
have any curated timelines with these
corporations deciding what you should
hear if you would subscribe to something
you would actually see it you would
actually hear it this curation has
essentially led to these larger echo
chambers to these larger to these larger
radicalizations and have pushed people
further and further apart on the
political spectrum where now we are in a
situation where people are at each
other's throats and we have to wake up
and realize that this was done by social
media so what makes you think giving all
your power to social media is going to
fix it this is such a frustrating thing
you see the direct fingerprint whether
it's the mental health crisis whether
it's the algorithm whether it's the echo
chambers whether it's them colluding
with intelligence agencies and
government agencies when you see this
problem
and and they they they have they're a
part of it and now you have people
saying they're gonna fix it all if you
just give them all of your power and
people are falling for it celebrating
this today you gotta be freaking kidding
me it's like the monkey's paw you know
that story it's like you get three
wishes but then it twists your wish
these leftists are like yeah censorship
yeah they're going to get these are all
the bad people the definition of bad
it's like a twilight zone episode where
it's like it was time now it's not fair
like why am i being banned no everyone
was finally banned and i could finally
have peace and then they're they're glad
they dropped their phone and the phone
shatters no you don't you know that
episode no it sounds like it's the
episode where the guy like just wants to
read and the world ends when he breaks
his glasses yeah he's got big thick
glasses so i'm imagining it's like a
leftist demanding everyone be banned and
then finally once everyone's banned he
has his phone he's like no i can look
and he drops his phone no well
information people need to understand
information is key during war one of the
first things that was done during the
iraq war from some of the reports that i
heard from frontline soldiers is that
there was leaflets dropped on
populations yeah of course saying
americans are coming they're here to
liberate you and here to free you so
this has been done as a part of
psychological warfare many times
throughout many important battles and
this is in the information were ramping
up to huge
just astronomical levels where
even fifth generational warfare doesn't
put a candle to it to what's happening
now and that's another term that people
should look up and should research
themselves when they want to understand
what is deeply happening and what is
going to happen from here in vietnam
they used to blast uh audio in the
jungle this like demonic sounds no no no
no no no no no and it would scare the
vietnamese because they were they were
all emotional and they wouldn't come out
that night no i gotta correct you talk
about informational warfare it was just
like
let me let me you know medulla oblongata
let me correct you please do
during vietnam the u.s would blast audio
of whaling vietnamese saying why did i
do it i made a mistake run while you
still can or you'll be trapped here for
eternity like i am because their
religious belief was that if they
weren't properly buried they were
trapped to roam the area where they died
forever the problem was it was too
effective
and the south vietnamese i believe was
the south who was working with us
panicked and ran when they heard it but
imagine you're in the jungle in the dead
of night with your gun and then you hear
a wailing ghostly voice crying and
begging you saying don't become trapped
like i am run while you still can
psychological warfare is crazy stuff man
it's like it's you know that old fake
story about the general and the pig's
blood
apparently it's not a real story but
they they talk about this this uh
general who after killing a bunch of you
know like uh muslim soldiers in the
middle east
poured pig's blood on them and left one
alive and let him leave so that he went
and told them and then they all stopped
fighting i believe that story is not
true but people tell it all the time the
idea being that he's like oh no it's you
know this is bad it's against the
religion and so he panicked told
everyone and then they refused to engage
psychological warfare oh you know what
it's simple pen is mightier than the
sword well they say the first step in it
is to control communication once you
control communication once you control
what people can and cannot listen to you
have a such a severe advantage over your
supposed enemies or even someone you
think are the nazis you know what
trump's mistake was he didn't watch
revenge of the sith okay because i just
watched revenge of the sith and you know
you know what palpatine did smart
palpatine
feigned a assassination attempt you know
when mace window comes in and then
anakin's there and then he's like don't
let them kill me i'm too weak and then
anakin you know ends up killing mace
windu and everything
i'm kidding by the way but it is it is
like you know trump is sitting there i
think i don't think trump had uh to be
honest
they're saying trump and cited and all
this stuff i don't i don't think so i
don't think trump intended for this to
happen when we had we had jack murphy on
recently and he was saying that it
sounded like when trump was giving his
speech it was a concession speech he
said sometimes it takes more courage to
do nothing and he was like what does
that mean you know like trump was trying
to wind things down well he said it's
going to be up to mike pence
yeah so like he he made sure he had no
responsibility at all and everyone was
like okay let's see what mike pence is
going to do and he released that
statement which
got around somebody somebody tweeted
something really funny they said how
long until trump uses the presidential
alert system to send him i was just
thinking about that when he tweet he's
gonna presidential alert his new parlor
account yes well there's even there's
even some scuttlebutt of them creating
their own social media networks well he
said that that's yeah that's what they
should do they should use the minds code
they should take the code's there the
code build your own network with mine's
code a government site man
more diversity i mean tim you've known
you've known to back up your social
situation the whole time you have to you
have to protect yourself and the fact
that you know he didn't it's
there's there's there's troubling
questions and troubling and dark times
ahead and and you know joe biden he
warned us he said a dark winter that's
what he called it a dark winter
and
i think the the the the challenge
is uh for us is
well i i should rephrase this i don't
think there is a path towards
de-escalation and i've said this quite
some a long time ago and i had it's
really interesting the left repeatedly
claimed that i was wrong and hyperbolic
and fear-mongering and all that for
simply saying look what happened this is
freaky why would it stop i'm worried
about this and then when it does happen
they're like why were you talking about
it you shouldn't have mentioned that
atlantic wrote about a coming civil war
like how dare you read what the
mainstream media is saying the issue
there was a tweet earlier from the
someone wrote in the washington post
whose i think was margaret sullivan she
said it was tucker's fault it was
hannity's photos fox news's fault and
i'm like if i if i recall
they were condemning the violence all
year and it was cnn who said who says
protests have to be peaceful
but when you see tweets like that
when you see democrats calling for
expulsion calling for escalation then i
i i would be more than happy to have
everybody just be like we don't want to
do this anymore who wants to go see a
movie i'd be like i'm down i don't care
what your politics are let's go grab
pizza and a beer and hang out and just
stop all this but you've got a constant
berating and beating and suppression
happening where
they didn't just go for the president
today they're going for his supporters
and they're nuking everybody steve
bannon's war room deleted
just the youtube channel's gone
they're making sure they're purging this
aspect of american culture i think
there's no linear uh path to
de-escalation maybe like you said
earlier it was there's a it's a
compounding or a uh exponential an
exponential escalation escalation in any
direction because of the way the system
works now it started with uh radio and
television that
you could speak for an hour but then
people could listen to it for ten
thousand hours even though only you only
spent an hour of your time ten thousand
hours of listening could accrue and or a
hundred thousand or a million and now
with internet video there's not just
it's not just on for an hour a day it's
on there permanently for like
exponentially more listening hours or
potential so change can happen
exponentially in any direction and
including a de-escalative function
totally agreement it could happen within
days if with the right powers in place
bill you brought up a good point you got
to be prepared for this stuff you guys
were preparing you guys have an
alternative i was preparing i've been
collecting emails on you know we are
change.org because i knew something was
coming
donald trump supporters are screaming
about this saying this is going to
happen to you you need to do something
you need to prepare
some of us have prepared uh but but
essentially you know let's just be
honest here he he i mean
it's not just that he wasn't prepared he
was sometimes ignoring individuals
telling him directly this huge
censorship hammer is coming your way
well like
how long ago was it that we were at the
white house a year a year longer than a
year it was like a year and a half yeah
and trump was just like what platform
should i use you didn't think that
someone well he knew he invited us
right yeah yeah yeah but he was
resisting because he has a very
mainstream approach to things it seems
like yeah he's an old guy yeah and he's
very tv he watches fox and all that and
he could have had i don't understand why
dan scavino didn't he's savvy you know
or at the time it was um brad what's his
name car scale car skill yeah why didn't
any one of these people say let us run
the account for you we'll set up we'll
have a parlor we'll set up a mines
whatever i mean what really worries me
is just the normal people sitting on
social media watching the preaching
happen and you know glorification of
this kind of event and like people with
good intentions actually do think that
this is helping and that that's what's
really scary it's like people genuinely
believe
that this path is going to make the
world safer
and i'll tell you i'll tell you one
thing
you take a look at the people with
connections the people with resources
and the people of great success
and what have they been doing
they've been buying bitcoin i wonder why
they've been buying land in rural areas
and fleeing cities for some time
they certainly must know something maybe
they don't all think the same thing but
they think something similar and when
you see people like i don't know a
couple years ago going on a major
podcast and warning about a coming
conflict due to censorship and then
saying i'm going to build a van so you
know a bug-out van and now here we are
with the capital being stormed
you know
you don't i don't expect like a plumber
to be fully tuned into what's happening
but there are people who base all their
investments on just they wait for warren
buffett to do something like he must
know something so i'll just buy what he
buys right
well when you see all of the people who
have access to government officials and
media institutions and intelligence
agencies fleeing to rural states red
states and rural areas and buying up
swathes of land should make you think
something about what's going on and what
you should maybe consider
another thing to really kind of deep
dive into and to really think about is
we're also seeing
something that is curated for us so the
algorithm the news feed the the curated
timeline they're showing you people
celebrating but that doesn't essentially
mean that a lot of people are
celebrating and those viewpoints can be
manipulated our perceptions can be
manipulated by what we're selected to
see
and already there have been studies done
showing how the timeline could
manipulate your emotions and how they
can make you fear
uh feel different uh you know emotions
just by deciding what to show you they
could do that on so many other different
levels and uh yeah do you know about the
confessions of the economic man yeah so
of course yeah one of one of the things
he talks about is that
in order to stage a coup in a foreign
country one easy one of the things you
do is you hire about a thousand people
to protest and film it and then from
those tight camera angles showing
massive crowds you say it's a hundred
thousand and then you you people believe
it and they think the country is you
know in chaos and then it makes regular
people freak out
we've seen a lot of things done through
various intelligence agencies with sock
puppet accounts which is you know bots
sock web accounts basically one person
will have 50 accounts with fake pictures
with fake names and they'll post things
attempting to manipulate and influence
people and this is an ongoing problem
around the world the u.s used to do it
all the time to manipulate foreign
countries the u.s government and they
still do and the israeli government
admitted that they had government agents
that are trying to sow a particular
viewpoint and a particular narrative
that are working by you know for from
the tax dollars to push the government's
agenda so this is something also talked
about by cass sunstein obama's former
information czar who talked about how
there needs to be an effort to undermine
uh you know individuals like who are
affected by not 11 like family members
who had questions about that event he
specifically talked about how the you
know the online community needs to be
infiltrated needs to have people who go
on there and make everyone else look bad
so people don't take some of these
serious legitimate questions seriously
and he talked about pretty much
informational warfare about how to
undermine any legitimate form of
criticism of government well there are
there are i'm not going to name the
companies for you know legal reasons
probably litigious but they dominate
reddit there are political organizations
that have training manuals on how you
derail conversations and manipulate
opinion so when a post pops up and says
you know donald trump does backflip
someone will comment i like backflip and
they have
they tell you if someone says i like
what trump is doing respond with this
and they they like have a script and so
these people their whole job is to go on
and comment on each other's posts
there's a really funny incident where
two people who clearly worked for two
different companies were commenting on
each other and and some like someone
pointed out it was it was like robotic
almost and they were like this is where
you can see where the tangle happens
when two companies trying to promote i
think it was promoting democrats
collided
and it created this weird loop of
nonsensical commentary comment because
they were just they weren't actually
responding they were like well the chart
says if they say this i say this and so
then it creates like a feedback loop you
know what i mean
it makes you really wonder cause i i'm
right now on twitter and i'm seeing a
lot of people celebrating i'm seeing a
lot of people i'm seeing a lot of the
reply guys who are going to be out of
work now yeah i love it yeah and
sweet and let's be honest some of it is
legitimate but then i also wonder maybe
some of the celebration maybe some of
the victoria that's promoting this
larger narrative and agenda could be
potentially manipulated i don't know i
haven't proved it but i just know for a
fact that it happened before with other
agendas with other special interests
that manipulated the system to to
procure a pers perception that leads you
to be programmed in a way that is
beneficial for those doing the
programming and that's exactly what we
have to understand here when we're
giving our attention when we're looking
at this timeline we are giving a part of
ourselves into this larger company that
could now take so much from us
when something's free you are the
product and they could twist it turn it
and they could be like well you know
well maybe he does need to buy this or
this they already know so much about you
it's absolutely terrifying so what can
they do with that information the
possibilities are endless and we should
not be kidding ourselves if those
possibilities aren't being used and
institutionalized and implemented right
now well that's the problem with
proprietary code in my opinion is that
you don't know what the algorithm is
doing which is why i'm obsessed with
minds i didn't even know when i met you
you were like hey let's build a social
network my first thought was another one
why there's already facebook twitter and
youtube we don't need one but then you
started telling me about free software
and the power of knowing what the
algorithm is doing to you so it's
literally doing things to us so it was
you bill who radicalized him into
screaming free the code i did
i introduced him to richard stallman and
linus torvalds but i mean it is true
like linux for for example like which
took over the whole operating system
infrastructure of the whole financial
system of the whole world because it's
free it's free i mean it and
that is going to happen with every in
well so let me just explain something
real quick to people to understand uh
linux is an operating system it's free
it's great and people realize that if
you're using some of these traditional
operating systems which you probably
know like windows you got to pay for
licenses
linux is free so just put linux and all
your servers yeah you go you save a lot
of money yeah so in the biggest even
facebook actu and twitter and google use
linux heavily yeah but then they build
on top of it and they don't share their
little secret sauce and that's because
it's an open source code and not a free
code like isn't there so there's
software codes where if you build on top
of it you have different licensing
structures and so the what the
difference is in open source software
like linux you can build on top of it
and make it private and then call that
whole thing private right but with a
free software code you can build on top
of it it has to remain free and so any
changes you ever make going forward
remain free and yeah it's called copy
left copy the principle of
having to share be right yeah copyright
yeah so you know and everyone should be
able to do whatever they want to do but
that's the funny thing that um you know
it's sort of a left principle i mean
both are good but it's everything's
switching and what you were saying about
like where you find the source of truth
when look at what the left and the right
agree on like the progressives and the
libertarians like find those people who
can talk you know dennis kucinich has
made a really interesting statement
where he's like you know me and ron paul
are like best friends basically back in
the day back in the day and they would
he said that on many votes if you look
back in the record it was always like
hundreds to two
and it was it was that it was them it
was the two guys from the government
both sides of the spectrum so if it was
like something involving civil liberties
or surveillance or when i would it would
be those two guys who who voted together
and yeah so you know that's where the
truth is and that's why like you know
some people don't like tucker carlson
but like glenn greenwald will get on
there and talk to tucker i mean right
you have like that's important so yeah
and so these people who are willing to
have the conversations but have
radically different political beliefs
but that's why they're all called right
wing now the weird thing is they can't
call jimmy right wing so they smear him
in other ways
they i don't they call him a shill or
whatever because he's not right wing
he's like screaming we gotta have
medicare for all and they're not
fighting for us it doesn't work but he
criticizes the democrats all the time
now tulsi gabbard she's
not right-wing she's also for
she's for universal healthcare with
private insurance that's that's what i
agree with and they attack her for it
for not being left enough it's crazy
like most countries in the world that
have universal health care on the left
is like oh all the countries do it yeah
they have private health insurance on
top of it and that's what she's for but
they call her right wing
they call all the glenn greenwald has
been right-wing for a long time it's
hilarious it's easy to slap that label
on but the funny thing is with biden
like he's always been like generally
moderate hasn't he like he traditionally
was was he a radical
no no no the better way to put it is he
says what he thinks he needs to say to
reach the lowest common denominator but
we also have to understand when we're
talking about individuals like tucker or
greenwald or tracy these are individuals
who also criticize trump right these are
individuals who actually have you know
still right virtues
who actually have principles who
actually have ideas that they believe in
that they don't flip flop on no matter
what the political alignment is they
rather go on merit rather than political
ideology which is something that's
extremely rare should be promoted more
but sadly we're seeing less and less of
and we're going to see a lot less of
that especially because behavior like
that was not incentivized by the
algorithms people knew if they wanted
more followers they wanted more
engagement they would metaphorically
take a dump on their political
opposition and they were dunking on them
and everyone was celebrating and they
were fighting and then until the
fighting gets so out of hand where here
we are today and this censorship they
know it's going to spread more paranoia
they know it's going to spread more fear
they know it's going to spread more
conspiracy theories disinformation and
false news and it's going to make it
worse so the fire is being fueled it's
it's out of hand already and it's going
to get a lot hotter in here
so that's my two cents yeah it's burning
up and it's it's crazy that
you know there are internal wars
happening at these companies as well
like one of the anomalies that i am
trying to understand it's like peter
thiel for instance is on the board of
facebook
he was a big trump
supporter i didn't realize he was with
facebook yeah he was peter teal was
facebook's first do you see the movie
the social network yeah you know when he
walked in that guy's office and he gave
him his first hundred k check or
whatever that was peter thiel peter
teals like a traditional libertarian guy
and granted he does invest in companies
that i think have really bad privacy
abuses i mean facebook uh palantir these
kinds of things but but he's also big on
bitcoin and he's playing both sides of
the spectrum and so it's just like
unbelievable that they're not seeing the
long game here
yeah his argument with starting talent
here was that they there was going to be
a 21st century spy tech and so it may as
well be us because we have good
intentions for people oh yeah yes that's
his mentality right
i hear a lot of dictators use that same
kind of law right right right we should
we should go to super chat yes so uh man
we got so many super chats in today that
when once we get too many youtubers
thank you guys well no that's bad i mean
it means yeah
too many come in and then the old ones
just
but you still get to keep the money
i'm just yeah i feel bad for people
whose messages you know yeah yeah i feel
like you're getting erased i like to
read them yeah you know so about half an
hour for the super chats you know sure
tweet any any ones that you gotta just
tweet destroyed them at us let's see
what we got here so uh if you haven't
already smash the like button subscribe
hit the notification bell and uh if you
want to support the show you can go to
timcast.com donates to donate directly
assuming you know eventually something
happens to this channel but we should
have the uh the full site up and running
soon yes
soon i mean like a few days or so so uh
that'll be good and then we'll have you
know uh exclusive content on the on the
website and it'll be great but let's uh
let's read some of these super chats let
me uh let me also suggest you smash that
gorilla and buy a teacher
t-shirt is officially up on the
teespring store
but youtube has to approve of it so if
you go to the teespring store which i
think might be linked below i don't know
then there's the i am a gorilla shirt
it's in there i saw you guys bought a
bunch of herrumph t-shirts last night
that was exciting oh did they yeah they
did well next we're going to put the
gorilla one on oh yeah and then we have
the iamagrilla love yourself which will
be fun correct daniel maxwell says they
want to prevent the center and right
from organizing and planning out a
political counter-attack the problem is
doing this is going to force us closer
to a violent solution which is not going
to end well for anybody
i i think i i don't i don't think this
organization necessarily other than they
don't like the other is bad i think both
sides think the other is bad and one
side is calling for censorship and one
side is calling for free speech the
censorship side is winning because these
people are squeaky wheels that never
stop complaining
when when you know
well event they call they control news
organizations but you know i'll leave it
there
somebody mentioned that trump tweeted
using the government account everyone go
read which we did read yes
let's see uh oh that was important one
oh megablade says can you bring the
puppy back in to help promote a healthy
safe space during this time of strife
tim doesn't want the puppy in the house
uh you can bring it in the show if you
want to go bring the puppy luke doesn't
want to get up he's too lazy
[Laughter]
the puppy peed too many times yeah a few
it's a lot of work we're training he's
chewing up the carpet too running around
shaking all flopping all happy
making everyone joyous
all right let's see
s-head says i've seen too many people
calling for revolution and all the
actions that will be the precursor to
civil war everyone needs to watch the
peter capaldi doctor who speech about
revolution maybe then they will
understand where it all leads to i wrote
a song about that
all right what's it called it's called
will of the people oh yeah where did you
listen to it on this youtube channel so
it's actually one of the top videos now
because it's got like 700 000 views
that's crazy i didn't think you guys are
awesome get it two million but uh that
would be great if those who are watching
you should check it out but if you
haven't seen the video and i and look
it's a video i made it's a song i wrote
and performed it was pr it was produced
by nishra allman
it is
about the cycle of revolution and how
these people who think they're fighting
for a better future will not get what
they think and uh as the saying goes be
careful when fighting monsters lest you
become one for when you gaze into the
abyss the abyss gazes back
but uh yeah check it out will of the
people on youtube on this youtube
channel you can search for it i'm also
hearing the quartering was just taken
down
no but that looks like he deleted it
okay so that's the initial reports
unverified now what i'm seeing on
twitter says the account doesn't exist i
got a message as opposed to this account
has been suspended you know when jeremy
got rid of his youtube channel no
twitter oh twitter he did it before he's
done it before yeah yeah yeah it's not
new
all right let's see
timothy hediger says terms of service
greater than first amendment well that's
the problem now isn't it
yeah does mine's terms of service
strictly adhere to the first amendment
mostly but like there's certain things
like malicious spam
that isn't in the first amendment so
i've been talking about rewriting a bill
of rights like an internet bill of
rights there have been documents i mean
there's like the manila principles
there's the santa clara principles
there's a number like yeah go to manila
principles.org actually it was drafted
by the eff
who
you know in some ways
they're the only
i think it's a similar ideology coming
out of them as the aclu it's like they
they sort of start john perry barlow
they're authoritarians
censorship they're not pro-censorship
though as an organization they tweet
pro-censorship stuff all the time
they used to be i used to be a big
advocate i donated go go go to the
hacker conventions eff i used to i
actually fundraised for the aclu at one
point now they're pro censorship they
advocate for removing people's right to
speech yeah repeatedly well they're
standing up for 230.
standing up for 2 30 yeah
yeah we need 2 30 reform to protect
people's right to speak not just blanket
keep it or or leave it
yeah nah i'm not a fan
anyway daniel nelson says to make
matters worse we can't even go to open
mics right now our literal public town
square for locals is currently not
available i am trying not to be very
frustrated right now and that's a very
important point none of us can go out to
public squares or to town hall or even
church where we normally communicate and
you're forced into these ideological
bubbles now they're banning they tell
you you can't go to church then they ban
you from social media these people are
going to burst man and the church and
the pubs have historically been a place
for organizing rebellions now they're
shut down coffee houses he goes on to
say anyway which foot should i be
catching pop shoves good question what
what that's not a good question it's
your front foot end of story i don't
understand
i guess if you're doing like a lollipop
shove it you do your back foot
left left foot or right foot was that
the question well that that wouldn't
make sense i mean you're talking about
switch shove it or regular shove it so
are you regular goofy what are you
talking about you do a nollie shove it
you could maybe use your back foot but i
guess the front would still be cool if
you did a lollipop shove it some jargon
there for all of you have no idea what
i'm talking about i am clueless everyone
in the room with tim
do you know anything about i have no
idea what it is that's nerd that's like
ewok talk
kelty skateboard jargon come on kelty
said my company in seattle just
announced it will hunt and fire
outwardly racist people online or in
private life participation chilling who
judges outwardly nra republican who are
the fascists
if you're not if you're look
you ever see that episode rick and morty
where the giant heads come
and then the guy
forms a religion where they they wear
clay heads show us what you got i think
so and then like they're they're they
whatever the faces do they interpret in
some ridiculous way and when uh rick and
morty's parents are like we don't want
to be involved in this then they tie
them to balloons and prepare to send
them to like to their deaths like that's
basically what it is we don't know what
we're talking about it's very it's very
bronze age tribal religious type
behavior
just adhere to the tribe do as you're
told no wrong think
you know yeah saying racist is a weird
term it's not even about racist though
it's just about are you a member of the
tribe or not will you conform or not
otherwise they'll chase you out that's
about it
all right let's see some more super
chats here timmy grice says my question
is for everyone in the room lids
included would you sideline your social
beliefs for free speech and freedom
what does that mean you could be quiet
would you underline your social beliefs
yeah
like i'm not going to push some so some
personal narrative to destroy your
ability to speak freely
yeah wait i i think it's a hard question
would i my beliefs for freedom of speech
like would i ever
give up on my belief
in order for other people to have free
speech but my beliefs are sort of an
oxymoron but what if what if your
beliefs were maybe they're not maybe you
think they are but would you put down
what you truly believe those who would
give up a little bit of freedom in
exchange for security deserve nothing
either we'll lose both
sam goode says hey
hey how does ian get things done
if you have to break break things down
to come uh complete individual
individuality tim you get angry to east
too easily to easily missing i'm a
social liberal and a financial
conservative
okay
it depends on get get done what i don't
know as i write it down people are
warning about what's going to happen on
the inauguration
video people are posting things online
about the 20th i think i think tim and
ian arguments are becoming a meme in
themselves well yeah but that's that's
kind of partly the point yeah yeah
tim reminds me of a lot of people i've
known throughout my life
well it's it is a meme like when you
weren't here the other day people were
posting no ian no peace yeah they just
got in there and they were and then they
were posting free the code
sing together it's magical it's great
it's yeah it's awesome no but people
were posting free the code in chat
because you weren't here dude they were
missing ian
gloves and a live feed yes let's do it
i'm here for it oh god dan orlowski says
the fcc sent out a message stating that
broadcast station that they have an
obligation to play the messages put out
by the emergency alert system really
i don't know
ever heard that akapot says ian you're
way smarter than people give you credit
for you rock man keep it up
i'm just uh i'm just an amalgam of all
the people i know your comment on the
limitation of right left is astute
google political circle it's not a line
uh actually gavin mcginnis drew a
picture and posted it once showing the
political circle yeah but it's it's just
another way to interpret um
like certain beliefs in a spectrum right
if you talk about left and right
economically it's easily aligned when
you talk about uh tradition versus
progress it's easily aligned when you
talk about authoritarianism then you can
make it a circle because
like there are certain groups that align
with each other but based on ideological
differences like racism or something
they'll agree completely like there are
alt-right people who are for universal
healthcare and left-wing politics but
they're racist so it's like their
politics their market ideas
are very similar but they have weird you
know culturally like people that want um
medicare for all but they're
authoritarian about it versus people
that want it but they're libertarian
like
like banned private health insurance
versus let people buy private health
insurance it's the authoritarian versus
the libertarian bernie sanders says ban
that take that away from people they
have no right to choose that's very
authoritarian it is yeah only the
government can give you your healthcare
the libertarian approach is
we will create the option for universal
health care and then you can choose to
get private insurance
because then you can have something you
know supplemental if you can afford it
or if you if you need it i don't i don't
understand the logic of taking away
people's right to choose that makes no
sense
dtr junior says radios equal free speech
bring radio broadcasting back
okay have you considered doing
terrestrial
i don't know anything about that would
be hilarious terrestrial yeah they're a
lot of fun am radio yeah they do
terrestrial yeah we were looking at
getting a ham radio shortwave radio yeah
we should do that we'd have to get like
a band and then we'd be able to
broadcast goodwill
there are certain licenses you need i
think yeah we have way too many super
chats today guys i'm so sorry
so let's see uh corey blair says
wikileaks just dumped link on parlor
uh
i'm not going to read any of that
on what he's saying because i don't know
if it's true but there's a lot in there
so i don't know if they actually release
anything but you know there you go oh
more people are saying it wikileaks just
dumped all their classified files on
clinton emails interesting really i'll
look that up
wow curious now
all right let's see travis ruiz says hey
tim thanks i was an active dnc supporter
until i saw what you were talking about
facebook is building a data center in
huntsville alabama the fbi is also also
building here and it's and then he made
an emoji face hmm
yeah i don't like the republican party
obviously i don't like the democrats i
don't that's why she didn't vote for
these people you know donald trump was
different
but not like donald trump is necessarily
a good pres look i think in terms of
certain issues that i've talked about
particularly war and dealing with
critical race theory he's been a lot
better than any president in my lifetime
like no new wars yep he's had problems
with with some conflict but it's been
you know
once i found out about the drone war and
his escalation and secretization of the
drone wars i got i lost a lot of respect
for donald trump and that was only like
a few months ago when i was talking to
luke about it on the show i didn't
realize that he had secretized uh
government authorization of drone
strikes now it's like on the high
command of the military
dan scope says order 66 has been called
the jedi defender of law and order have
become enemies of the republic and must
be removed next step is transfer
emergency powers to the chancellor to
get us through the crisis i just watched
raven's revenge of the sith the other
sith the other night
man it's so different watching that
movie now that i'm older i can't
remember what when did that come out
like 2000s
2001 is when the first one the first
prequel yeah but man the dialogue is so
corny and like oddly acting i mean
what's his name george lucas just not a
good dialogue writer i don't think so
and his directing making him act that
way was weird but but it is uh uh uh
i think it's an interesting you know
analog in a sense or analogy like
order 66 they're now purging people i
wouldn't necessarily call the people
being purged jedi you know because it's
you know it's nuanced politics force
sensitive
no
well
depending on who's getting banned you
could say that there are people who are
perspicacious what's that mean uh an
acuteness to comprehension of reality
like oh that's awesome yeah perspective
yeah right yeah perspicacious
yes uh let's see
nate hammer says removal from office
after impeachment requires 67 senators
two-thirds to vote for it that's right
so a simple majority would not be enough
it's not gonna happen
i mean
i really don't think so there are people
posting something i've seen some some
democrats post this they said
uh something the effect of josh hawley
and these and these uh other you know
republican congress members of congress
will gladly accept a trump fundraiser
down the line
and i'm like yes they will
but that what they're trying to imply is
it's a bad thing that must be stopped
what do you mean trump fundraiser like
in the future trump will hold a
fundraiser for political candidates oh
and then they'll go and shake his hand
and all his supporters will be there and
some outlets have said he'll be a king
maker he'll choose the winners and
losers when it comes to the republican
party because they love trump and the
argument from these people who are
posting about it is that it's a bad
thing that must be stopped that they
can't how do we what did abc say abc
were not saying how do you cleanse
the trump movement
you know from from the republican party
or whatever yeah that's that's language
exactly right
key low says if they expel all the
senators and reps that supported trump
how do you think the states they
represent will react
um secession
no taxation without representation if
they expel representatives from a state
that supported trump that would be crazy
the senator there's no representation
for the state it would be outrage what
were you talking about before about sort
of the governmental um
sort of
check that they're doing on people's
beliefs with cops oh luke brought that
up
okay
well i'm just looking at my twitter
sorry i was distracted there was like
a thousand followers yeah justin house
ass purge going on it's crazy but you
you were saying that like the cops are
gonna be vetted now they're gonna go and
check them uh well there's a new report
that the uh capitol police officers will
be investigated for ties with white
supremacy after debbie wasserman schultz
congresswoman released a statement
saying that she thinks that there was
insider uh there's an inside job that
yeah she's she thinks the us capital was
an inside job no she thinks that there
was officers who helped people get in
they did
um and she thinks that some of them had
ties to some of the protesters and now
we're getting information that all the
officers will be investigated for quote
ties of white supremacy but what does
white supremacy mean we've had that
argument we've heard people called nazis
for for just the simplest smallest
littlest
microaggressions so
again who knows i'm seeing rumors that
cloudflare has removed 4chan but i'm not
i haven't i saw it earlier i wasn't able
to confirm it cloudflare that's like
amazon web service right they're like a
cdn
this is slowly becoming content delivery
china when it comes to their control of
the internet uh if you look at what
happens when a small group of people
control the internet you essentially
have china then you essentially have the
social credit score then you essentially
have them literally using american
twitter to talk about how great it is
that uyghur women are no longer baby
making machines and that it's great for
gender equality that they have pretty
much essentially concentration camps for
them it's so important to contextualize
how the rest of the world is looking at
us right now like okay yes people are
probably disgusted with what happened at
the capitol but
like people in oppressive authoritarian
government regimes are looking at this
censorship and like
being like what are you doing i mean
they our problems are just so much less
than what's going on in in these
countries where they can't even go on
the internet at all and we're banned our
our companies our private companies are
banning people from the internet we
we've got major major breaking news i
don't know if you guys saw this earlier
but olive garden put out a statement
about sean hannity and banning him from
the never ending possible viscous
attacks
uh uh we have we have a statement from
sean hannity saying i never signed up
for olive garden's never-ending pasta
pass hannity says it's fake news how can
you ban someone from something they
didn't have i don't think olive garden
ever actually said it i think someone
made a graphic because it was hilarious
this idea
vicious oh and what in the viscous yeah
everyone was mocking it matt tybee was
mocking it
interesting
that's like who got banned from some
service from like monkey
something they didn't have mailchimp
yeah yeah yeah from now on
yeah they didn't even have a mailchimp
yeah he said they just claimed it
because activists claimed he did so then
they announced they banned him even
though he was never with the service
yeah
let's see
airsoft master says hey tim if google
facebook and twitter kind of companies
keep heading the way they are going in
regards to limiting speech do you think
we will ever be able to backtrack to
before all of this or is it to the point
of no return
look
if you only ever ban more and more
people then eventually there's no more
people left to ban and it'll be jack
dorsey sitting in a small room going
like i think
um there's
my opinion is better i'll pay myself and
then i'll just like that's it
and then then that's an empty server
with nobody in there they're going to
build every eye for you to interact with
if you want a social network where
they're still populated it'll just be a
bunch of artificial
i'm wondering when they're going to
build love simulator the video games
some people say tick tock was allegedly
doing that but who knows
wow yeah
when you ban everybody then nobody is
banned i guess technically that doesn't
work because then nobody will be on the
platform but imagine twitter just bans
everyone and then what happens when the
left can't actually get to an argument
anymore so they start going to parlor
because they've started doing it they
actually go there and they and then they
post screenshots laughing about you know
owning the cons or whatever and like the
stupid things they post and i'm like
there you go so it'll be like it'll be
like digital drive-by arguments where
like twitter will be left-wing and
parlor will be right-wing and then
someone on twitter will go to parlor and
then say something screenshot it and go
back to twitter and
it looks like they banned rush limbaugh
whoa yeah
yep good times yeah he's totally gone i
don't think we're ever gonna be able to
go back to where we were no way we'll be
able to move forward to a different
dimension like a different
way of internet like i don't think the
centralized proprietary services are
going to be the future of social media
yeah it'll be more of a you know
decentralized i like this r weave block
blockchain um
you know mesh net type i think there is
a large group of people who do want to
talk to people who are different from
them and you know rational democrats
republicans people on the left to right
who want to go and find someone
that's different from them there's a
pocket of people that exist like that
it's probably a small group that's more
what we're trying to do on mines.com
have the conversation cross spectrum be
open to both sides not just
not just one side or the other but you
know it is definitely you know you can
either ride the divide and that's what
all these big networks are doing and
that's what some alternatives are doing
or you know you can try to bridge people
together but it's way harder we got a
super chat here from chris christopher
yager he says tim vastly overestimates
the degree to which the right would be
using social media and internet to
organize in a civil war scenario not
necessarily i just think it's a powerful
tool but with that being said there's a
really interesting story i read once
that i don't know if it's true or not
but i read it in the context of
non-fiction i think it was in a magazine
or something or some website they talked
about how there's you know modern
warfare and then there's the archaic
forms of warfare we used to have and
they were doing a training scenario
where they brought in a retired you know
general or high-ranking officer to lead
a group to do a war game scenario
against the current you know you know
military the modern warfare
and the modern group with all their new
technology and everything lost to
rudimentary and old-school tactics and
technologies
and what they did was the linchpin for
how the retired guy defeated the modern
army was that the modern groups were
relying on digital technology for
communication and so the old school guy
slipped a note into the pocket of a guy
in a motorcycle to trans transfer the
orders and they didn't know how to track
what was being done or what they were
saying or where they were going to do
and they were trying to monitor
communications through radio and it was
just a guy and a bike with a note in his
pocket gave him the orders and then took
him by surprise i don't it could be just
an apocryphal story about
not forgetting your fundamentals maybe
it's not true but it was a real it was a
much much much longer story about like a
warning maybe someone online has heard
that story before but it's really
interesting does it make sense you get
you get caught up in what you expect and
you ignore the simple the simple
solutions so yeah ham radio people
talked about that and ham internet you
guys know about that no there's like i i
don't know a whole lot about it but
people using ham radio to get really
like you know
internet signals yeah but it's real slow
but you can send like
characters and text and stuff yeah using
hammer yeah
yep
dennis attic says luke where did you get
your shirt
oh that's such a nice great question
really appreciate that yes you can get
my shirt on we are change dot org
forward slash shirts and they go towards
keeping me free and independent and here
so thank you guys so much for uh where
you know buying and wearing my shirts it
means a lot to me dennis also says tim
would you would make my day if you said
i am a gorilla in a deep voice i did my
best
um we do have the iamagrilla shirt
coming it is done it's on the teespring
store in the description below is the
link to the teespring store it should be
there you should be able to see it and
then youtube has a separate approval
process and then once it's there we'll
feature it and then the next one coming
is the iamagrilla love yourself see you
know the shirts we're making are silly
like me with a bubble pipe saying haromf
and luke's got these very serious like
the world the apocalypse is here and
we're all doomed essentially but they
sound pretty good and i think it's it's
it's a great way to meet people i mean
when i when i wear the shirt um
especially the toilet paper one i have
one that talks about the pyramid of
control and on top is the toilet paper
manufacturers yeah it starts
conversations and then underneath is the
illuminati and then underneath it is the
cia the media but but again it starts
conversations which is important because
then you could see someone is a part of
your tribe someone is thinking the way
you are and it's a great way to build a
community i mean when i'm walking around
people like man i love that shirt i love
that hat and and i'm able to talk to
them and know someone in the community
that that is thinking the way that i am
so it's a great way of bringing people
together garhant says tim the military
one is the millennium challenge 2002 and
it's lieutenant general paul van riper
i'm sure i got a lot of the story wrong
because it's like 2002 i probably
haven't read it a long time but that's
the gist of it so i'll look into that to
see if that's the story because there's
a really cool story when i read it
let's see scott uh brumley says any
truth to google and apple banning the
parlor app yep yeah yeah i don't know if
apple's done it yet but i know google
has yeah and you oh we already talked
about that mines has been through this
before yeah you have to basically i
to if you to the to the parlor people
here's my recommendation for how to get
out of the google thing uh well
email them and say hey did you see
well for us we got banned because of an
explicit image of a woman naked
it was behind it was behind a blur and i
just emailed them back after six months
and i was like you realize twitter has
full porn
and they were like oh yeah oh yeah and
so i think you just got to try you got
to find someone inside honestly it's the
only way but like they were accusing you
you guys are like not moderating or
something yeah but you do moderate yeah
we do of course yeah yeah we have like
deep nsfw filtration tools and i i don't
know if parlor has that but you need
that i'm pretty sure parlor has pretty
strict rules yeah i thought i thought
they used to be more strict they were
doing like fcc policies that's what i
thought they were doing but then they
switched oh yeah i didn't know that yeah
so i i it was people were getting banned
for like
not that crazy like it was worse than
twitter like swearing yeah they were
banning people for like dropping f bombs
and comments
because it was fcc broadcast standard
and it made sense like i got the idea i
don't think it makes sense no i i mean
like someone had the idea like i know
what if we use a tv standard that way
people have they can say things you
can't say on twitter but we're still
having moderation that should be
satisfactory because the tv does it like
you can you can turn on tv shows and
they i'll tell you this cobra kai right
you guys ever see cobra kai a little bit
i watched the first season it was
awesome i just stopped watching after
that because you know i don't really
watch a whole lot of tv but they said
things in that show i can't say on
youtube but it was a youtube original on
youtube how does that make sense pretty
that's crazy i like that
johnny he's a good actor he has a good
show
tjl431 says i'm just joining and i know
it's late but have you discussed google
has taken down parlor it doesn't work on
my android anymore wait it doesn't work
on your android i know you can't go to
the store and get it anymore it wasn't
working because it was overloaded
so lauren says tim you said to buy
ethereum and the price jumped 0.15
just before the show we were talking
about crypto like before when live and
bill was like oh ethereum man you got to
buy it and i was like you think i should
and you're like oh yeah and i was like
okay and then i bought it so then we
were talking about crypto i was like you
know bill mentioned buying ethereum i
have ethereum i'm not a big fan of
talking a lot about crypto but uh it
needs to be talked about but the risk is
there's a lot of people who try and like
talk about something because they want
the price to go up that's stupid can you
explain the proof of work to proof of
stake that they're doing yeah so i mean
ethereum
is proof of work like bitcoin now all
the miners are running around the world
and basically securing the network and
the miners are earning money from
the that process but they're moving
towards more of a proof of stake so you
can you will in the future be able to
mine ethereum on your laptop oh i see so
you can stake your 32 eth on your laptop
and it's more decentralized
theoretically more secure but some
people like proof of work bitcoin is is
you know
big daddy so it basically just means
like mining is the way bitcoin produces
coins
ethereum is the same currently but it's
going to be transitioning by holding a
certain number of the coins you
facilitate the ethereum network but you
have to stake them into the protocol and
run a program on your computer oh
yeah that takes up energy and costs
money yeah well i mean but you can run
it on a laptop like the thing with
bitcoin mining you need serious
equipment to be able to have it what is
the cost benefit
it's just the the eth protocol the like
in each full node yeah you have to
explain it to me i guess yeah yeah you
are so oh and basically you earn
interest so you earn like six percent a
year by staking your eth
and you need 32 of it yeah okay what do
you where do you need to put it in order
to start staking it i'm honest i i
honestly don't know uh you get six
percent yeah you get six that's huge
yeah and there's actually a cool this is
a little bit of a name drop but
particularly for bitcoin you can earn
interest at this
site block fight this guy anthony
pompliano is on on their board he's
definitely anyone check
interested in bitcoin check out pom he's
an animal he's amazing um i went on his
podcast a couple years ago but blackfy
you can earn interest on your bitcoin
and eth just by holding it there now
granted i'm not necessarily recommending
that because you're putting custodial
custody with them but it's just i mean
gemini and coinbase you're giving them
custody so right the beauty of crypto is
you can hold down on your own device you
know and you're saying you got a ledger
yeah which is great you can do that put
into cold storage and so you can have
sovereignty or you can use these
services that can give you interest but
with eth it's moving towards more of
like decentralized finance and these pro
there's all these protocols like uniswap
and whatnot where you can plug into and
earn interest by providing liquidity and
it's like a whole new financial system
that is is blowing up there's even like
decentralized like insurance
protocols and lending protocols so
you know have you considered doing it
with the minds token mines is an
ethereum based token and it's on yeah it
is we are doing that yeah so you'll be
able to earn interest in minds tokens by
storing it and by staking it you will be
able to in the future actually where
really
look at this guy's got a smart on his
face when i said it's not it's not out
yet right right that's a teaser that's a
teaser but definitely check out
mines.com token if you want to learn
more about mines.com uh yeah you know
which is a platform you can use for
social media as the great purges yeah
and our whole thing has been to help pay
people and we're doing rev shares as
well with mines plus mines.com plus
we're taking 25 of the revenue of the
company and proportionally sharing it
with all of the users who submit content
to that wow and
yeah so you know fiat that's the big
crypto that's the biggest thing that
that helps you know uh youtube maintain
its position is that it's where you can
have a job it's where you can make money
so that's the big challenge mostly most
these networks can't handle it google
subsidizes it absolutely that is the
amazing thing about youtube i mean maybe
crypto will be the key maybe maybe the
value of crypto is going to go up so
much that you see makes a new yeah the
library token went from like two cents
to 10 cents in like the last couple
months i can imagine as the mine's
utility token starts to gain well how
what's what's the trajectory of the
mind's utility token what's your plan
for the next couple years for it
coming soon oh interesting
but you can buy it somebody just made a
comment steven vero says just sold my
ethereum and will buy twitter options
puts twitter will tank soon let's make
some money boys and lids
i don't know if that is a good bet i
don't listen i don't have any stock in
twitter
but i wouldn't be surprised if twitter
tanks with with trump being gone and
maybe it's not thousands of people being
censored maybe it's thousands of people
leaving that's what i was saying yeah
yeah the trump's gone so they're like
i'm out yeah i didn't want to mention
twitter earlier in the show just because
all this what we're talking about today
i was like tweet me out i feel so dirty
is you know what you feel better when
you leave come come to the oh i'm on
mine all the trump reply guys people who
built careers off of waiting for trump
to tweet to say something dumb
they're out of jobs
all of these journalists there was one
journalist from buzzfeed she tweeted
that my mornings were haunted by trump
who at 5am my phone would buzz and i'd
have to see what it was well you are now
being relieved of duty congratulations
trump is gone you don't have to wake up
early in the morning when trump tweets i
feel bad for some of these journalists
they're not all the trump haunting you
know rage bait there's like some legit
reporters who are like
they're going to make me write about
this aren't they this is so dumb and
they're going to be like look people
want to know what trump is saying it's
all over
it's gone it comes off the idea that
people are going to chase him to
some other network just to complain
about him yeah that's gonna happen dude
i worry about his mental health i'll be
honest i feel like yeah
he gets he gets bullied hard and he is a
bully and so he he asks for it full out
but like the way that people treat him
it's like it's like your family member
who you just like their attitude there's
something about them that you just can't
talk to them because they're so annoying
and they just always need to win he's he
is that but at the same time it's just
like people need to realize that that
that's his personality and just get over
it well he's also on social media a lot
and anyone who's on social media and
doesn't take a break that has an effect
on your mental well-being i always
recommend and i always do this
personally myself once a year at least
take one week or two weeks no cell phone
nothing no facebook no twitter no
instagram no ethoding nothing
two weeks clear
somebody just made a comment we were
talking about this earlier
aurora diaz says in rwanda the media
called on the public to kill their tutsi
neighbors and the moderates that
defended them are we heading towards
genocide
you know what's funny
people people always think it can't
happen here
and i was reading about uh you mentioned
this before the show ian the jews
fleeing germany yeah
and uh i was reading about a lot of them
did a lot of a lot of jews in germany
left once they saw things getting crazy
i used to wonder why didn't they all
just leave before when they saw it
getting crazy and i i i'm not a
historian or anything but i was reading
an article that said they thought it
can't happen here and so they just
dude if don lemon no offense don i'm not
not prying you but if someone went on
the news and said that to go kill people
it would happen that's crazy that people
would go out there and hunt them down
it's the people are that
animalistic when when when cuomo is on
is cnn is is basing their ratings like
predicating their strategy upon
demonizing 75 million people
they know they've lost the audience and
they've given up
so instead of saying let's make a
network that is more balanced so we can
communicate to as many people as
possible to make money they said now
we're not going to get those people just
get the others what happened was the
polarization started getting so extreme
that network started picking a side that
would make them money because the center
don't pay that well let's be real that
is the problem that's honestly our the
the demon that haunts us it's like we're
trying to play the center role and not
polarize
but people love the drama the live
streams well the algorithms love it too
and they incentivize it and that's what
they say you have to train yourself to
want to see people's opinion on the
other side it's actually a reflex that
you have to build i've always followed
left and right yeah and that's and
that's one of the biggest problems they
have the left doesn't follow the right
the right follows the left that's a
common theme we see on major social
platforms and so i'll see buzzfeed
writers tweet about trump and then i'll
see a trump supporter tweet about trump
and i'll be like ah i see what they're
saying and then when i tweet the
craziest thing is
i'll tweet something like you know ted
cruz condemned the violence and called
for reconciliation and then aoc
immediately responded with you should be
expelled and resigned but the left
doesn't see what the right is talking
about and they're like but aoc is right
he should be and i'm like yes you're
part of it you're the problem they call
that demand for escalation and what's
really interesting is even during
obama's first administration when he was
still the hope and change guy end the
wars bring back privacy for the
individuals i had a subsection of my
audience that was like just admit it you
should be an obama supporter you should
i was like no some of the things he's
saying and promising is is good but it
won't happen same thing with donald
trump people are like support donald
trump just do it i'm like no he's
sitting down with kiss and i criticized
him throughout his presidency but now
people are like he's not doing anything
they're not doing anything regarding joe
biden there is no spirit of hope and
change there is no spirit of of people
that
baseline support him so it really really
really makes you wonder what's going on
he's the ma president yeah no i think uh
it works out really well for the far
left
they didn't like trump they don't like
the populist right they were able to get
rid of the populist right while putting
in a very weak president
which they say is easier for them to
overthrow so what they did was they
created a universal just you know an
enemy for the populist faction
but he didn't sound weak today when he
compared u.s representatives no he did
he did he actually did weak you think
that was weak he was mumbling and like
he always mumbles
him sounding weak isn't the issue
it was the demonization it was very
strong words it was strong words
presented by a very old feeble man
indeed but you were reading them not
hearing them what the journalists do is
they translate for biden joe biden could
say like you know i went down i i went
down uh i you know the the i went down
the shop i was at the shop and then the
article will say quote i was at the shop
they cut out all the
struggling
and then and then they say but he has a
stutter
it's like come on dude that's not
stuttering when you when you say the
things he's saying the speeches he was
given just a few years ago compared to
the speeches now you see a big yeah big
difference
so look the rhetoric is they bring up
rwanda and the tootsie and stuff
you know what man
we're not there right now
but they have been saying for a long
time
to kill the nazis and twitter allows
this
do they say that kill them yes really
yes that explicitly that's like the
illegal constitutional world it started
with punch
yeah i remember that and so the the the
issue is
when i was on with you know was two
years ago now with with joe and jack
there was a tweet from antifa explicitly
advocating for violence and i said this
has been reported hundreds of times
probably it won't be removed
and and then joe pulls it up it's like
oh yeah wow they're like explicitly
telling people to go take an action and
go do something illegal twitter won't
remove it
so what happens when it's not so much
about people going on tv and doing it
but on twitter they're literally doing
it right now i bet you go on twitter you
pull it up you'll find it and then what
happens is they're gonna start saying
and they've already been saying that
trump supporters are nazis
trump trump is hitler and so what
happens when they go on and they say
it's not your tutsis they say it's the
nazis
right they go on the media and say you
have to go you know stop these people
before it's too late
so so if you say to code kill a type of
person and then you say that guy is that
type of person you're essentially saying
but twitter allows it
is it not constitutional
well i'll tell you this i bet if you if
you posted you know
to take action against a communist you'd
be nuked in two seconds
but nazi's different it's the
brandenburg test the brandenburg test is
the is the uh
legal precedent for imminent violence
what is it
it's just
is it imminent or not yeah and that
means is it true you said it was changed
now to is it a true threat of violence
yeah it seems to be sort of changing
internally i think in the state law of
pennsylvania they were using the
language true threat but the supreme
court precedent is the is the
brandenburg test
whether or not they're actually telling
someone to do something right now
that's so weird
well
let me take a couple more super chats
see what's going on over here people are
talking about rush rush limbaugh getting
suspended
let's see woody would like me to read
his super chat let me see if i can find
it
so look i apologize to a lot of people
when we get slammed with super chats
it's it's huge and it and then we can't
actually track everything
so i'll try and see if i can find this
super chat
and when you have thousands it's just
becomes
it's a lot tonight
oh here we go
woody says tim i understand non-violent
civil disobedience but the point of 2a
to bear arms is to provide that check on
government tyranny my question is when
is such action necessary a misguided
attempt from the mostly peaceful
protesters for sure but where's the line
um
we had vosh on the show and he mentioned
nazi germany and i think everybody would
agree if they're rounding people up onto
trains to bring in the concentration
camps to be you know max genocided you'd
probably have to fight back you have no
choice because they didn't know where
those trains were going yep
and then we have that bill coming out of
new york the have you seen this one was
it a a14 or something like that that
says that they can remove and detain
people suspected of having contact with
someone who may have a communicable
disease like that's how any disease now
it's not passed but it's been introduced
basically it would allow cuomo
the power and anyone who signs the power
to remove anyone without legit cause now
of course the bill says they must have
clear and present evidence of a
communicable you know public health
threat epidemic or contagion contagion
or whatever
what does that mean
it means they're going to be like your
delivery guy tested positive for covid
so you are coming in the truck yeah and
like where is the truck going they
didn't that's the thing that the jews
didn't know they were like hey we're
going to put you on trains and take you
to a resort they were telling them we're
going to take you to like another town
or another place to set you up they
didn't tell them they were going to go
take them throw them in ovens so
yeah maybe they should have used weapons
to defend themselves but they didn't
know that that's and that's and that's
the problem what happens when
someone comes to your house and says
we'd like you to come with us sir and
you just say okay
so that's it's tough i don't know man
it's crazy that it's almost the perfect
storm of of reasons and rationality like
with with all the covet
stuff all of the political
as well it's like there's these two
major reasons that people are sort of
getting isolated into these groups and
it's it's crazy that both are happening
at the same time yeah well i think it's
fair to say it's going to get worse not
just because of the political collapse
of the right but because of the oncoming
tsunami of financial consequences that
are going to be there because of the
lockdowns because of this kind of larger
idea of the great reset which the biden
administration is going to be pushing
admittedly so that's what i can said
yeah john kerry a part of joe biden's
administration admitted that the great
reset is going to come faster and
quicker than many people expected and
it's going to be done under the joe
biden administration so when that
happens that's going to be another major
ramification the major efforts to take
away people's second amendment is going
to be another major clash point and
we're headed towards a trajectory that
is really really dangerous for everyone
even if you're in the middle especially
and again not just even if you're in the
middle to the people on the left as well
it's going to be against anyone not
toting the official line not loving the
government not being obedient to them in
every possible way so keep that in mind
we had so many comments saying that it
was really easy
to
you know advocate for peaceful
non-violence or uh nonviolent civil
disobedience when you haven't had your
life destroyed by the lockdowns and all
that stuff
and that's a fair point except you know
a fair point in terms of the stress
i just don't think what they did at the
capitol will actually make things better
it'll make things worse it'll justify
the lockdowns like gretchen whitmer said
when they protested the lockdown she was
well now we got to extend the lockdowns
because you all came outside
that's what you get
so i guess what i advocate for is
self-sustainability in independence and
security protect yourself protect your
family and your friends learn how to
survive and be self-reliant try and get
away from the cities at the best of your
ability but i do feel that you know with
with uh the talk from fauci and bill
gates about this extending into 2022
going through another what year and a
half or two years of this
i think that statement alone is them
telling us they intend for violence
because they know
we've seen the mass rioting already now
on both sides the rage that came from
this this lockdown also that that would
take in in in
not in um that would insinuate that
they're going to print like another 30
oh yeah
yep and then if they if they're
specifically they said new normal you
know we'll be in this normalcy won't
come back from until 2022
which means yes
people either are going to get their
stimulus checks or they're going to get
crazy yep it's almost like ubi is here
yeah to a degree like they might just
keep doing it on a regular basis and the
idea might be
by giving people a ubi but but taking
away their ability to work and produce
things
you end up with people only being able
to buy bare necessities it's almost like
they v they i if i were to imagine
it being on purpose i'm not saying it is
but it's almost like trying to sweat out
a fever you ever hear that you know you
you you get a fever so you throw all the
blankets on and just sweat as much as
you can to just but then you got to
rinse that salt off your skin well so
the idea would be
they think the world is being depleted
of resources and it's true to an extent
it is and there's there's fishery
collapses there's insect population
collapses there's really scary stuff
going on they fear climate change and
now the great reset explicitly talks
about this and so the idea is simple
smother everyone
give them only just enough to survive
to eat and recalibrate them that's what
they mean by the reset interesting so
everybody says they don't care about the
movies verizon tweeted the other day do
movie theaters have a place in the new
normal and i quoted i said this is a
really weird tweet it's really weird
they deleted it it was really weird yeah
um and i think most people said no
yeah it was a twitter poll
so
ultimately
they will probably have lockdowns going
on for a few years
they'll give people only just enough and
it'll be fought over relentlessly in
congress and then i think some people
will snap if the left doesn't get their
two thousand dollars per month they'll
snap if the right sees the country
printing and just essentially
devaluing the dollar like crazy
and then they can't run their businesses
and fulfill their own lives and purposes
and have freedom they'll snap
so
i'm not optimistic about the future
unless everything comes back to normal
which is probably not going to happen
i don't think so we're 28 trillion
dollar deficit or uh close
27.7 trillion right now closely
approaching 28 they had to print like 6
trillion this year in order to match
that it would have to be more next year
because the dollar is worth less so
you're looking at at least like
10 trillion next year but that and but
we haven't worn on lockdown this whole
year so it'd be like
10 to 12 trillion next year and then
that would extrapolate into 2022 to like
another 18 or 20 trillion so like
your dollar might be worth
it's not just three times less it's like
we should we should open the show with
the debt clock calculator yeah every
time
pop it up like this smash the like
button
the federal debt to gdp is now at 130.51
130. it was at 126 two weeks ago yeah
124. and then joe biden announced his
economic team today and his larger
economic plans of spending more money
immediately two thousand dollar stimulus
he says and
check to every person to every 200
million people um 330 because they give
kids they give money for kids so like if
you're a family of five you your wife
and then all your kids get compensation
i think kids will get less that's like
you know a couple hundred bucks per kid
but what is that going to do when the
dollar is worthless people who have
bought bitcoin will in the land of the
collapsed dollar the man with bitcoin is
king so that's like six hundred dollars
billion dollars a month is what they're
looking at two thousand dollars a month
this is what they're looking at i mean
omar has called for 2000 a month think
about the the mass amount of money
they're printing every month if that was
the case i think canada implemented a
kind of similar system i have to look
that up though
what's interesting is a lot of people
are saying you know the other day i
mentioned i bought bitcoin and they're
like tim's buying the top you know you
should wait till it goes down and i'm
like
well you can look at the massive spikes
of bitcoin in the past where it's a
broken all-time high broken all-time
high and it does fall down i think
bitcoin may go down as possible but i
also think those dips didn't happen
right around the time those dips didn't
happen right after
a bunch of people stormed the us capitol
building and there was a
chaotic transition and mass purging on
social media and 66 of all us dollars
being printed in one moment so i kind of
think people are buying bitcoin in fear
you have mass mutual an insurance
company putting a hundred million of
their treasury into bitcoin no you have
really fidelity
you have micro strategy a publicly
traded company putting 500 million
dollars of their corporate treasury in
because it is digital gold yeah the
million you mentioned the crypto market
cap is now a trillion the market cap of
gold is nine trillion
we're going there
bitcoin is reading the financial system
it is the new printing press and elon
musk one of the world's if not the
world's richest man hinted at even
investing in it with tesla
i'd like to i'd like to tell everybody
something okay
uh
what was it 2012
bitcoin was at what like a dollar
yes you could have you could have walked
outside excuse me sir might i have a
dollar from you i will pay you back sure
i don't care keep the dollar okay bought
one bitcoin and then just walked away
you'd have forty thousand dollars right
now
forty thousand you could buy a tesla
you could buy a tesla with one bitcoin
there's a it was it was okay in november
it was at 13 and it's at 40 now but the
thing is like i said
we are seeing people storm into the
capital building we are seeing mass
printing of the dollar it is not the
same as it was last time some people did
sell off when it hit like 42 because
it's like whoa they get scared and then
i'm like i'm buying the div it's a big
market money
how can you have faith in a financial
system that literally is just
hitting zero on the keyboard wow
one problem with crypto is the entire
market is a trillion right now the
entire crypto market cap of the world is
one trillion and so it's going to get
really big the us government just
printed six trillion yeah so they could
have bought for all we know that market
could have been co-opted sure it's being
controlled it probably is by big money i
was talking about this we're talking
about this before the show the
likelihood the us had the the ability to
just buy 51 of bitcoin to control the
network perhaps and you mentioned we
won't know and that's a good point i'll
put it this way i am i personally am
confident in bitcoin and i'll tell you
this if you mentioned what are these
companies mutual insurance mass mutual
put in fidelity jp morgan just predicted
that bitcoin will hit like 150 k i think
bitcoin's going to go over a million
yes yeah yeah absolutely and i think not
i'm not going to say that i think it's
going to happen i don't know when it'll
happen but i certainly think so because
if we're talking about 1 trillion market
cap for bitcoin and entropy meaning a
lot of bitcoin just doesn't exist
anymore it's already out of the supply
21 million cash it's one trillion for
the entire all the cryptos combined oh
all the crypto yeah bitcoins at like 600
or 700 billion
that actually is better for my point my
point is if these big companies are
hedging in bitcoin and it's nowhere near
enough compared to the size of the us
economy then bitcoin has to become worth
more because of the finite amount of
bitcoin available i wonder if bitcoin's
an inferior coin and it's only super
valuable because it's popular
first and best dressed yeah a lot of
people have said that
it it it is the the fairest system
that we have what about litecoin it's a
fork of bitcoin i know and it's like
it's like 86 million coins so they they
used to say litecoin was the silver to
bitcoin's gold
yeah i don't know i'm i'm more just
bullish on eth and and bitcoin
particularly bitcoin when ethereum came
out it was
people were like this is a revolution it
was like bitcoin
was a revolution and ethereum is like a
revolution on top because the the smart
contracts the program programmability of
ethereum essentially bitcoin was like
the buy the printing press came out it
revolutionized and the first thing it
printed was the bible to show that it
was a revolution bitcoin is the bible
it's the first printing on this new
revolution of the blockchain the
blockchain is the printing press
yeah so
i'm i'm not a big fan of these all like
alt coins these other yeah you know i
think it's silly and that's why um i do
have a couple like on my website you can
you know donate some couple addresses
there's a lot of scams out there there's
also a lot of predatory behavior you
have to be aware of that and you always
have to be super careful and it could go
back the other way it's it's a new
testament will go back the other way and
it could be used to track trace database
and spy on you and some people even
believe it's a honeypot who knows that's
another that's why there are and there
are privacy coins like zcash and monero
which actually are interesting they just
got banned from some u.s exchanges for
like probably surveillance reasons yeah
the irs released a statement that
they're trying to crack and break down
monero
so that led to a lot of people investing
in monero uh essentially so i saw ripple
got shredded they're proprietary dude
and the the ceo sold one point six
billion of it without notifying the sec
i think got in trouble and now yeah not
okay that was never a fan ripple was
kind of the big brother big bank coin
and they got chewed up by the big
establishment that they were trying to
cozy up to
so so we got we got a funny super chat
let's read this um minuteman says elon
musk said he's more worried about
population collapse than too many people
if you work out the math of population
in earth's livable land there's not too
many people ps got pulled over by a cop
who's a fan of yours how did how did
that come out like you got pulled over
he was listening on the podcast yeah
like or like where he was in the car and
he was like oh you're listening to this
probably
dude there's a hilarious visualization
read the code and then fist bumps
of uh of all the humans on earth in a
pile that was right right it's an actual
visualization it fits in like an area
it's yeah
you look up the the visualization of all
humans in a pile please do well
it's funny but look the issue is not the
livable land it's the impact of a person
per you know
transportation of goods well so we had
on uh uh chris martinson
a phd and he said insect populations are
collapsing and that's the bottom of the
food chain it's gonna affect birds it's
gonna affect a bunch of other things and
we're gonna see that it's gonna be bad
for us plus uh pollination of plants so
that's a serious you know crisis yeah
there's a great video called the
overpopulation is a myth that brings out
some scientific data that kind of
suggests a lot of different things that
you don't really hear on the mainstream
media that people should check out in my
opinion i think that elon's boring
company is way
bigger than people realize right now i
was trying to investigate but i think
tesla owns it it's still owned by tesla
right now how boring it's owned by him
it's not public um but once we start
living underground like if we can have
livable tunnels we've just doubled our
land space
uh without going very far yeah
it is a beautiful performance
that a a guy trying to move the world to
sustainable energy is now the richest
man in the world and he wants
us in your head
yeah that's the odd part yes i don't
think so they're not chips yet i think
i think it's a health
benefit for people who are struggling
right that's one of their use cases like
if we had brain computer interface and
the scale of usb i think it would be
amazing the challenges are encryption
security and making sure that when you
plug something into your brain
you can't be compromised anybody who's a
fan of ghost in the shell you guys are
familiar with ghost in the shell i
haven't seen it
long story short in the future people
have cyberized brains people can hack
your brain so that's a consideration for
if you get a neural link i'm not i'm not
saying that uh i i think a lot of people
get scared like i would never get it and
i'm like well look
if you were losing your memory and
technology right technology is neutral
somebody if you if you have a parent who
has alzheimer's and they said with
neural link we can use a usb
that would act as a memory backup and
make sure they their brain you know
people would be like absolutely yes yeah
it's just an issue of security
technology is neutral it's the
application and so there are risks for
sure did you see the pig demo of neural
link i saw just like snippets i didn't
really know there's a picture oh you got
a lot of three pigs with yeah it's the
demo and you can hear the the data it's
read only right now so it's just
transmitting what the pig's smelling and
seeing and showing you is like okay
what's a dolly i think it's her name
i want to say dolly that she was the
sheep that they said oh dally's the
sheep like the matrix we got
i want i probably shouldn't read that i
want to read this read it sparky the
pyro says apparently 4chan is now trying
to get everyone to change their name to
donald trump and use his picture it's
called operation spartacus
i love it
i love it i can't stop them all timothy
edgar says wrong dollar equation why
turnover is at zero when money turnover
goes from one to two watch out
turnover meaning one example i don't
know
four three two four three two uh what's
jumping on me
four three two cycles per second says
all bitcoin maximalists are now ethereum
maximalists because they are not stupid
also don't count on the blockchain
failing except for solar flare or
nuclear war
interesting um you could also store it
in glass in the blockchain in orbit so
maybe a flare wouldn't affect i don't
know about dna did you guys hear this uh
phoenix says tim the u.s seized
pirate-based bitcoin billions worth and
it just moved recently look it up
anyone hear about that no
didn't know that but if the any all
governments who are smart are
stockpiling for the purposes of the
treasury and you were saying that there
is risk in that and that there is for
sure
i think uh
i've been i you know i have some bitcoin
i wish i bought a way more what you know
back in the day and i regret not
listening to max keiser max and stacey
max and stacey
i love that meme have fun staying poor
and did you like him drinking a martini
or whatever did you hear sean lennon's
uh intro to their new their podcast oh
no he didn't yeah he made he did it for
them it's really it's really oh it's
awesome yeah i don't know that was [ __ ]
yeah i'm just gonna say it again if you
listen to max and stacy you'd be super
rich right now and if
that's he was talking about repeats
itself i know i know uh he's been right
about so much for a long time yeah and
this was back in like 2012 he was like
you gotta buy bitcoin
and and it was like a couple bucks i
love the way he just went for the throat
of the banking system after the collapse
in 2008. man he was vicious and just
right on about how criminal they were
about the money they took and the obama
bailing them out we're hoping to get
them on the show soon they don't want to
travel for obvious reasons but uh max
and stacey are amazing eventually stacy
yeah and uh i wish i listened to more to
them they're actually advisors and mines
oh really yeah cool yeah yeah the good
people well you've been on max's show
yeah
if you have the orange peel podcast yeah
right on yeah if you oh no no no it was
on his rt show oh yeah i haven't been on
this that's a new show the orange pill
are they still doing the rt stuff i
don't know if they are yeah i don't know
they're doing the orange pill podcast
and it's like the orange pill there's a
colored pill for everything but it's
bitcoin
and uh
i think he's right man he's right yeah
if you haven't already smash that like
button we'll do one more we'll do uh uh
one more super chat here let's see we'll
do two more super chats mickey the
fourth says there's amazing channel
called radical liberation focusing on
in-depth analysis of geopolitics doing
weekly streams they recently did an
episode on how the scientific theories
of overpopulation have been here to
justify
stuff for 200 years must watch
interesting we'll check it out and we'll
just do one more it's the perfect segue
as we begin to sign off
julie simone says love the addition of
luke to the show hit me up if you need
any puppy training tips congrats on
becoming a dog dad oh thank you i'm
doing a lot of training it's it's a lot
of work and
uh keeping up my own independent media
organization and coming in here it's all
it's a lot of stuff but
we'll see where it goes the cuddles are
worth it yes
super cute does she like bite your feet
in the middle of the night uh no we're a
crate train
yeah okay okay that's good right now you
want her to like the crate yes as sick
as that sounds
but then they grow up your cage they
feel like it's their own home and they
actually prefer yeah
my friend had a dog that when he would
train her she would bark he'd grab her
throat and pinch it and then she never
barked well you want to use positive
reinforcement so whenever she does
something good like when i call her she
comes to me i give her a treat when she
parties outside i give her a treat you
don't want to really use negative
enforcement especially with breeds that
are known to attack their owners you
kind of want to keep them they say that
works with humans too uh you can yes
there we go you want to keep things
happy so the dog's always happy and
always pumped up and always
you know the tail is wagging so that's
what i've been doing maybe i'm making a
mistake let me know so right on my
friends smash the like button subscribe
notification bell it really really does
help engagement is good for youtube
youtube loves it and uh now the fun part
if you want to uh follow me i'm on
twitter instagram and parlor at tim cast
presumably for the time you know for the
next for the first evil future but you
never know because things are getting
absolutely crazy so you can also check
out my other youtube channels for the
time being hopefully for the foreseeable
future
youtube.comcast and youtube.comcastnews
and we do the show monday through friday
live at 8pm so subscribe give us a good
review on itunes it really really does
help and if you haven't checked us out
there you can check us out on all
podcast platforms bill thanks for coming
and hanging out thanks for having me man
i love you guys not only do you have
social media accounts you have an entire
social media network yeah yeah no tim
tim is uh
tim is one of the rock stars over at
mine so don't forget to shout out mines
in your little uh reg
yes mines.com
you know it's funny with the little
social media icons that people put on
their websites like you know the trendy
ones and you know you just gotta yes all
the alternatives do do cover yourself
cover your own bases everyone out there
join them all just just do what you can
so mines dot com slash ottman ottman
right on oh luke
you sell shirts yes i sell shirts i was
gonna say check out my small independent
mom and pop media organization on the
youtube channel we are change but i
think it's more imperative you go to we
are change.org and definitely sign up on
that email list so we could talk
together without some head honcho
oligarch standing in a way between me
and you there's also we are change.org
forward slash donate which you could
support my independent voluntary efforts
here and there's like 20 different ways
where you could get involved and i
really really i mean i got to admit it
like the people you have here the people
you've been able to galvanize tape
amazing individuals
some of them are like facetious and they
make a lot of funny comments but i i
seriously seriously one of the best
communities that you've been able to
foment and build here awesome amazing
human beings thank you guys so much uh
for uh for coming to my channel too and
checking out as well and spreading the
support and love it it truly is crucial
and important more than ever that we get
the word out now
uh well we can while we can yep oh well
hello tim thank you thank you
yes you can follow me ian crossland at
most social networks twitter youtube
facebook which i don't really check
instagram and minds of which i was a
co-founder with bill uh and it could be
very well the future of social media if
we maintain its free software
methodology also smash that gorilla and
share this share this i don't think tim
mentioned yet tonight but i want to
encourage you to share this content
because
in the day of you know
computer simulated algorithms that are
deciding what people see you still have
the power to show people things you like
and and ian if every single person who
tuned in today shared this we would be
bigger than cnn okay then it's possible
shares are more more powerful than any
than ever that's right you can also
follow at sourpatch libs you can you can
follow me on twitter i'm on twitter at
sour patch lid sour patch l-y-d-s and uh
post random stuff is today friday today
is friday wow yes we'll be back monday i
will be uh back tomorrow morning on my
channel over at youtube.com tim cast
news but we'll be back with the show
live 8 pm monday so again smash the like
button subscribe check us out on all
podcast platforms thanks for hanging out
and we will see you all next time bye
guys
you